Experience,
ladies and gentlemen,
Maxwell fresh from Australia,
international man of mystery,
world traveler,
trainer of the stars.
You're out there buddy.
Good Day mate.
They a they call it stray.
Yeah.
S t r y a stray.
I was,
that was checking out my uh,
my Australian memes,
you know,
all the uh,
Australian slang,
pretty funny man.
You can go online and Google this stuff.
There's some of those things they have are absolutely hilarious.
So you were telling me before the show that you just started getting into t h c
a k a
marijuana.
You know,
it's funny,
I'm a child of the 60s and the 70s,
and you know,
that was the huge hippie era and I was a wrestler.
I was like hardcore athlete,
wrestled Ncaa Division One.
And um,
for me at that time I believed all the anti propaganda,
you know,
I was a pretty straight laced guy and uh,
so you know,
oh,
it's a gateway drug and Oh my God,
you're going to go to hell in a hand basket and you know,
this stuff will destroy your brain and,
and you know,
blah,
blah.
You've heard it all of course.
And um,
what was that?
What was that really funny?
A anti marijuana movie that they had back in the madness?
Reefer madness.
I actually,
we had to watch that in health class when I was in high school.
Yeah.
There's part of the school curriculum back in the 60 [inaudible] so they showed
it to you,
like is this real?
Yeah,
like it was real.
We all believe that.
So remember I was from little,
uh,
Carlisle,
Pennsylvania,
you know,
got some of me that's like a hick town.
So yeah,
I just recently saw reason,
uh,
just about maybe six months ago.
What happened?
What started it off?
You know,
I just had so many friends who were into it.
And it's interesting because I made observations.
Uh,
I've been in Brazilian Jujitsu now for,
oh my God,
since 89.
How many years is that?
Like,
yeah,
20 something.
Yeah.
Okay.
Probably 6.6.
Oh my.
Well,
most every BJJ champ that I know was totally into marijuana.
They give it to use it to relax because it's such an intense sport,
you know?
I mean,
if you think about it,
it's such an extremist thing.
Um,
what do you do?
You go out and try to hurt someone as much as possible,
but joint locks and so forth,
and what were you choke him to sleep.
Right?
Of course that being said,
I had way more injuries with the college wrestling that I ever did with,
with Jujitsu,
cause he can always tap.
Right?
But I just noticed that these guys,
you know,
it's an intense sport,
maybe not as intense as MMA,
but it's certainly up there and they all would light up at night and so forth
and you know,
that has her bongs or,
you know,
roll up a joint.
And I,
I could just never
figure this out.
It just would blow my mind.
Right.
And over time I just got more and more curious.
So,
um,
I had,
I had a lot of friends in Australia that were really totally into this also.
And uh,
I just decided,
you know what,
maybe I'm missing something here.
You know,
now that I'm in my sixties,
you know,
I missed the sixties so I made my sixties so I'm going to check this out.
So I started playing around.
I've got one of those.
Um,
what I didn't like was the smoke,
I find it really irritating,
but I tried one of those,
the cost to the vape,
it's like a little square box with a little straw books.
I can,
we take a little kid's juice box,
right?
Adult juice sparks,
they have a bunch of those now have pens that like,
they look like a,
like some sort of a metal cylinder with like a lip on the end of it.
And you and you,
you pack it with either oil that you can buy pre prefilled little tubes of,
of hemp oil or THC oil and stick it in there and it has some sort of an element
in there and it heats it up and you're just breathing.
And vapors is a vaporizer,
a portable vaporizer.
So yeah,
I was just very curious and um,
well I,
I mean I,
I you,
you've been into this for a long time.
Very open about it and I thought,
well,
you are really into your health and your body and you take great care of
yourself,
and I figured,
you know,
if it's really all that harmful,
Joe wouldn't be doing this.
There's no way that you would do something like that.
Yeah,
I was with you.
I mean before I started smoking pot,
I was in the same boat.
I really thought it was for idiots.
I thought it was for people that just wanted to escape reality.
There were weak,
they couldn't handle it.
They just wanted to get drugged out.
I thought about it the same way I think about pain pills today.
Like I,
I've,
I took,
I've had three knee surgeries.
My first major one,
my first ACL was a Patella tendon graft,
which is kind of,
it was particularly painful because they slice your patella tendon,
they cut a chunk out of your knee cap and a chunk out of your Shin Bone and then
they drill it all in place and screw it in place.
It's good because it's a native piece of tendon.
So it,
it,
it hears the body very quickly and there's very little chance of rejection and
it's a very strong,
but uh,
it's very painful and they gave me a prescription for Vicodin or some shit.
I took,
one of them won and I remember sitting on the couch feeling so stupid and foggy
and I said,
I am done with this.
My other two surgeries,
my,
my other ACL and my other meniscus surgery,
I didn't take anything.
My knee,
my a nose.
When I had my nose fixed,
I had my deviated septum fixed and my turbinates cutout,
my no stretched out and they put tubes in and everything.
Nothing.
I didn't take anything,
just pot.
And,
um,
I don't like,
I don't like anything that leaves me like cloudy and that seems like that's what
I thought pot was.
I thought pot was something that left you stupid or cloudy
and it's really just,
it's the opposite.
It tunes you in.
I was shocked.
I was utterly shocked.
The first thing I noticed was my vision improved.
I've been near side and most of my life.
And um,
I basically found my eyes were getting worse each year,
getting stronger prescriptions.
I finally read this book,
take off your glasses and see.
And uh,
I just basically threw my glasses in the trash and started doing ice
strengthening exercises.
Kind of neat.
I'm going through that right now myself.
They improved a lot.
There's a lot of different exercises you can do,
but um,
the,
the name of the book is take off your glasses and say,
hmm.
And this guy was a disciple of the Bates method of,
uh,
I strengthening,
but when I was at the summit of the breath masters in Moscow,
they had a bunch of guys there that,
uh,
we're using a breathing and I exercise and all sorts of stuff for the
improvement of vision.
One was a former,
uh,
Spetsnaz snipers,
so I guess he knows a thing or two about vision training.
And he was showing some of the August just has a seizure.
I was,
you know,
a real simple stuff.
And it was like,
wow,
this works.
But only to a point.
It got really good to the point where I can drive during the day.
I still a little reluctant to drive at night.
I mean,
I could,
but I can't read street signs at night.
During the day.
I can actually see signs,
uh,
but I'm a little reluctant and the,
um,
but I noticed with the,
when I would take the THC,
I was using one of those vaporizer things.
It was like my eyes would start to really clear,
which leads me to believe that it has something to do with muscular tension.
I noticed that my digestion would improved and instead of getting foggy,
like I would be on my iPad,
maybe doing an email or something,
it's like somehow my fingers would just glide over the keys and just magically
find the letters way faster.
Or at least my perception of how much faster.
I Dunno.
It was just a very interesting experience.
Well,
one of the things that people use it for with Jujitsu is not just to relax after
training,
but before training because it focuses you in a very tunnel vision sort of a
way.
When a eye roll,
when I smoked pot and role,
I feel like I'm better at Jujitsu.
I really do.
I feel like more relaxed I feel,
and not just more relaxed.
I feel like I'm more sensitive.
I'm like more in tune with what's going on.
I'm also,
I love stretching on it.
That's one of my favorite things to do.
I love eating one of those things.
Those jumbos I just gave you that say,
yeah,
I haven't tried eating it.
That's an all organic edible,
a THC,
you know,
marijuana,
little cake thing.
And it's all with natural honey and all natural ingredients.
It's like probably the healthiest of all these edible ones cause a lot of these
edible ones are using processed sugars and high fructose corn syrup and stuff.
It's not good for you.
So this guy who created these,
he decided,
you know,
there's gotta be an market for an organic of these marijuana edibles.
So that's much healthier for your body,
but it's a really strong,
be careful now going to be very careful.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I have not,
uh,
in truth taking it before I've trained,
but I read about the guy in Colorado,
the triathlete,
he's world class athlete,
um,
very elite and he,
he's been really advocating taking it before endurance training.
Somehow it improves a pain threshold.
Your,
your tolerance to physical exercise,
pain,
not pain,
right?
But like exercise and do discomfort.
It changes the way your body reacts.
It changes the way your body reacts and any sort of when I work out with it.
But if I lift weights with it,
I like,
I can feel the fibers or at least I feel like I'm feeling,
I feel the fibers of my muscles.
I feel I'm very sensitive to it,
which is one of the reasons why I really enjoyed doing it before I stretch.
And Terence Mckenna,
who is a late,
great psychedelic philosopher,
he,
it was his contention that yoga itself was really a how to use cannabis manual
and that the way to optimize your experience with cannabis was through yoga.
Cause all of those saw dues.
All those guys are just a hash smoking freaks.
They're all like one that's like the dark secret of the sod dues he would say is
what they really concentrate on is how many chillums can you smoke before you
pass out?
And they,
you know,
you're not a man unless you can go deep,
deep,
deep into the rabbit hole.
And these guys would smoke massive amounts of Hash and do yoga.
And,
you know,
I,
I used to think,
oh wow,
that's kind of crazy.
Like I guess they're just having fun and doing it until the one time I did yoga
when I was high and I was like,
wow,
this is amazing.
It's like I can relax more and get deeper into poses.
And also I feel like I feel this,
the resistance,
like a lot of,
uh,
Pavel,
talks about this as well.
I don't know how to say his last name.
How do you say his last,
that sewing sat soling who's a one of the most famous advocates of the Kettle
Bell,
he,
uh,
talked about stretching being a big part of what holds you back is a tension,
psychological tension,
not necessarily even flexibility,
but that you're worried about your brain sets up that stretch reflex.
Yeah.
When you're in an unfamiliar position.
So it's,
you know,
it's saying danger.
You're in a different position than you're used to being in.
For most of us that's sitting in chairs or most most people,
right?
Yeah.
That's the most,
yeah,
that's the most common position.
Right.
And when your head's in between your legs and you're stretching your hamstrings
out,
you know,
you,
your body is threatened by that.
But was like,
what are you doing there buddy?
Tents it up,
tents it out.
Um,
what he was saying was that it's all about like breathing,
like resist and then relax.
Resist.
And they were,
but that resist and relax is enhanced.
I don't know how many fold when you're on marijuana.
I mean,
it's amazing how deep you go into stretches and how good it feels afterwards.
Is this weird state your reach when you do yoga or any type of deep stretching
on marijuana?
I'm a huge,
huge fan of that.
Well that's it.
I'm a neophyte man.
Uh,
teach me master.
I,
yeah,
I think it's amazing and never let it be said to Steve Maxwell doesn't
experiment.
And you know,
I,
I really think that one of the secrets to aging well is to be open minded and
just to experiment and learn new things.
Try New things.
And Jill,
be such a stick in the mud with,
with your belief systems,
you know,
don't get so holier than thou with all,
all your beliefs because hey man,
you know,
have you think about it?
A lot of really high spiritual adepts,
they all use some type of either,
you know,
a hallucinogen or when we talked to last time and the show about Iowasca and so
forth and you know,
the shape and the shamans use and they're raw mushrooms.
And I think as you get older,
I think especially when you have been around a lot of fools,
you reach a certain point in your life where you don't want to tolerate any
nonsense and you're just like God,
enough of this nonsense like what you need is you know,
a nice,
a good diet.
You don't need any supplements.
You don't even need any hooey and your life.
You don't need any BS.
Just get out of bed and go out and do it.
And that,
that sort of mentality serves you well.
But in having that mentality and meeting all these fools,
sometimes you can kind of develop prejudices.
You develop these ideas that aren't necessarily based on data.
It's more based on like sort of just your perceptions of the people that are
around you.
Like if you see enough losers that do something,
you'd say,
well that's for losers.
He see enough losers that are smoking pot.
You think,
well,
pawn is for losers is obvious.
Like look at all these losers spoken pot and then you meet like Bj Penn.
You're like,
wait,
hold on.
Bj Penn,
good high and does Jujitsu.
Like wow,
what's going on there?
And then you,
you know,
you,
you find out that 90% of the Brazilian Jujitsu champions are smoking pot and
rolling this stuff.
Yeah.
So it's an,
it's a performance enhancer.
There was actually an article recently about ultra marathoners.
Jamie,
see if he can pull that up.
Cause it was,
I forget what publication it was in,
but it was a big article where people were really being really shocked at these
are the results and these guys that were ultra marathoners that we're advocating
smoking marijuana.
And they were talking about should this be banned from ultra marathon?
Well I'll outside magazine also a thing could have been outside of there as soon
as that Fox was right here and there were a bunch of different things.
Yes,
marijuana has benefits,
but is it ethical?
Yeah.
See this is the thing.
Well people of course it's ethical.
Is Our vitamins ethical?
Is Fruit ethical?
Is Caffeine ethical?
It's a God damn plant.
I mean these people are all on caffeine.
By the way.
Here's the dirty secret about marathon runners ultra.
I have a buddy who is my friend,
Cameron Hanes is a fanatical runner.
He 10 miles a day,
sometimes 15.
He does marathons,
he's done an ultra marathon.
I think he's gearing up for another ultra marathon.
He's a maniac and he's always hopped up on the caffeine always.
But he has a job,
like a regular job and he can't touch the pot.
And I've been telling them about all this and he's like,
maybe it was another good reason why I should quit my job.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
um,
there's another very interesting thing I've been experimenting with,
but for years,
and that's the,
uh,
the state of brainwave meditation where you actually,
your brain produces different levels of brainwaves.
Your brain oscillates at certain speeds and different parts of the brain produce
different,
you know,
like Alpha,
Beta,
gamma,
Delta,
theta.
But they just like the one that's most closely associated with that sort of
between sleep and wakefulness.
When the subconscious mind can be programmed.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of really good programs out there.
It produces a beat and then your brain starts to adapt and copied the beat.
And you can slow the brainwave dam.
It's what I did in the plane.
I just,
like I said,
I flew in from Sydney like 14 hour flight man and didn't really get that much
sleep,
but I did one of those [inaudible] beats theta brainwave meditation.
Now this you're wearing headphones?
I,
yeah,
yeah.
I actually was using a Bose earbuds,
noise cancellations and just sitting there with my iPhone and just wow.
Zoning.
And you,
when you come out of it,
you feel like you just had a refreshing sleep.
Really?
Yeah.
It's very,
very relaxing.
Speaking of relaxation.
And so for those folks that are still a little leery about maybe trying
something like THC,
you can do this with the theta brainwave meditation.
All of the brainwaves like have their benefits.
The alphas,
like what we're in right now,
the Alpha and the,
uh,
the Beta,
like while we're awake.
GAM is like when you're in a real deep sleep,
like real deep dream,
like state,
the theaters like that twilight,
you know,
when you're the,
this is when,
when people meditate,
they go into a theta brainwave state.
But by listening,
you could meditate like a monk your first time out man.
Wow.
Yeah.
It doesn't require any special breathing or postures or anything.
You could just literally sit or lie down comfortably and he's just going into
the zone.
And if you do practice visualization or if you practice any kind of affirmations
or subconscious mind programming,
it's a great time to do it,
man.
So you're listening to a program,
what is the name of the program and how do you get,
there's a whole bunch of different ones.
You know,
you can go to Amazon or iTunes and just look for a theta brainwave meditation.
I'd recommend,
maybe people just go on,
uh,
you know,
just Google it and look at the different,
I mean there's so many different companies out there now.
You can get cds,
you can get a um,
uh,
[inaudible],
you can get it downloaded.
An Rj,
I have it on my iPhone.
That's great.
It doesn't programs and it's really handy for,
for guys like us cause you do your fair share of travel when you have to adapt
to a new time zone.
And it's pretty hard to sleep in some of these points?
Sometimes do.
Yeah.
It's hard for me to sleep on planes.
It's also hard for,
well,
you know,
if,
if I'm tired I can conk out pretty much far down on the floor it goes.
But,
um,
it's hard for me when I have to do something like three hours and I know well I
can take a nap right now for two hours.
Good luck.
Almost makes you feel worse than if he didn't take it at all,
which I lie there and I go,
I go to sleep,
come on.
I usually can't get there.
But you slept the earphones on,
but your,
your binary or beat,
that's just like a one,
one of the programs.
What does it sound like?
Um,
well sometimes they use music.
You can hear like an underlying beat.
It's just underneath the conscious hearing and,
but you can,
you can kind of hear like a little rhythm going on and sometimes they'll have
the beautiful kind of angelic,
you know,
music.
Uh,
sometimes they just have like sounds of the ocean,
you know,
like ocean waves,
incredibly relaxing.
And you just find yourself zoning and when you finish the program,
you really do feel like you had just a very nice refreshing sleep and you feel
quite,
quite excellent.
So they vary in the sounds,
but the beat stimulates the same part of the brain.
There's a couple of different techniques.
So one,
uh,
what are the techniques?
They have a different rhythm going in each year.
Wow.
So the right and left hemispheres have to synchronize with each other.
What if you're bipolar?
I don't know man.
Yeah,
man.
You know that I,
I'm sort you out.
Mean I'm not a,
I'm not a brain scientist,
but I have been doing this for a bunch of years with good results,
but I don't know if maybe if you have a mental illness or bipolar sent them,
but they do claim that it regulates your hormonal levels.
Really.
Yeah.
And there's even,
there's a,
even to the point of producing growth hormone and so forth,
have you ever messed around with any of those?
Um,
uh,
do you know the turbo sonic is,
it uses sound waves through the base of a platform.
You stand on this and it,
and it takes you through a bunch of different cycles I have and its sound,
but you don't hear it.
It's like you're,
you're standing on a stage just getting fucked,
shaking,
just getting vibed.
You'll have loved that thing.
I have one of those things in my house and it's supposed to like do all sorts of
things as far as stimulate the production of various hormones and you know,
an aid,
healing and circulation.
But it makes you feel great,
but there's not ways you can just exercise and,
and,
and do vibrations and so forth.
You know,
and trampolines are really good for that,
right?
Yeah.
I mean the Dallas Yogis and the she Kong,
uh,
practitioners have been doing similar things with their own bodies.
I mean obviously the platform makes it much more convenient.
Oh,
it's 10 minutes.
You get on that sucker for 10 minutes and you're like,
hey [inaudible] he goes through all these different,
like you'll do like 10 seconds at one and then 10 seconds at another and then
very fast,
high frequency and then low and slow shaking.
I'm,
or no,
and when it's all reelect,
God,
I feel so fantastic.
Yeah,
it's wild that a felted craze,
he was,
you know,
they have like a,
a bouncing,
shaking vibrational kind of thing.
And there's a,
uh,
like I said,
the Dow Yoga just have a thing where they do this kind of stuff.
Uh,
when I was in Russia,
they,
they had as part of their raw Slavic Russian Russian health system.
If their mobility stuff,
they would have shaking and vibrations and,
and all of the stuff that you just kind of do it yourself.
And I read this guy I'm Alexandra at and he was a,
like a psychiatrist that treated people with,
uh,
with,
chronic mental problems with the exercise and so forth.
And really he was really big into shaking and moving the body and all these
interesting patterns and it's very relaxing,
just gets a lot of the tension out.
And I agree with you.
I,
I do believe it,
it does help facilitate a recovery.
I think mental problems and relaxation are so often not connected with each
other.
Mental problems and exercise and exertion.
And the fact that a lot of people,
a lot of the tension comes from a not releasing energy and their body stores up
this energy like a battery and then it's leaking all over the place that it's
just like there's short circuiting when you see people screaming and traffic and
you know,
and cutting people off and right.
All this madness that,
I mean it really is like a form of madness when you see someone screaming at
someone that's not even anywhere near them and traffic,
the stress levels just get so much.
And a lot of that goes also back when we talked about this last time too about
your breathing patterns.
Most people and I do seminars all over the world and we test ourselves to see
what type of breather we are.
This,
like one of the things we do first and amongst everybody in the seminar is like
a Co vicular breathe that they're using the emergency apparatus of the upper
neck and chest,
shallow breathing,
breathing,
and it's panic braiding.
And all those emergency receptors are in the upper lobes of the lungs and
they're not bringing the Otu down into the lower lobes.
So they're in a chronic panic,
they're in a heightened state of village.
It's all the time.
That's exhausting man.
And it does all sorts of weird things to your hormones and it definitely,
it's hard to be in a good mood and relaxed when you're in this panic state.
Your subconscious mind doesn't know that.
There's not like a threat looming over the horizon.
So everything that happens is perceived as a threat.
Every little comment,
you know,
someone cuts you off in traffic.
People take it so personally cause it's,
it's a threat because they're all caught up in the chest.
And Man,
I'm telling you,
when you learn to do proper diaphragmatic breathing and bringing the breath down
to the lower lobes of the lungs,
it's incredibly calming.
You know,
you can do that with.
So what,
what do you recommend if someone is looking into doing something like that?
Is there a book that you recommend or a program do you have?
Yeah,
one of your seminars.
A lot of breath work,
you know,
well master Hixon Gracie now,
uh,
if,
I mean for years he never showed us his breathing system.
You know,
he'd be kicking our ass and doing this kind of weird breathing.
And I used to think as he making fun of me,
you know,
that's kind of what this weird kind of thing he was doing.
Yeah,
exactly.
All hoists,
Hoy,
you know,
they all knew how to do this and they weren't teaching us blue and purple belts
at the time but now he's spending a lot of time teaching.
I heard that crown also is spending a lot of time cause I think it's really,
really important for combat athletes to,
you know,
learn to read the acts and the way you relax in combat is through breath
manipulation.
But as far as actually being taught,
I haven't seen it that the systemic guys do a pretty good job with it,
you know?
But,
uh,
it's funny because,
you know,
I started really getting into this reading a lot.
Um,
but I wasn't reading stuff related to combat as much as mostly yoga stuff.
You know,
where she come.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's Kinda hard to find the information.
Yeah,
it is.
It's hard to find information.
It's hard to know like what's the best program for you?
I guess you have to try a few different ones,
what you enjoy or what,
what seems to benefit you.
But I think,
um,
when you,
especially when you're dealing with martial arts and you're dealing with,
uh,
training and,
especially competing,
you're dealing with extremely stressful situations where your body's pushed at a
very high pace where,
you know,
you reached the point of exhaustion and then you have to continue for,
three,
four minutes while you're exhausted.
Everyone who's ever rolled has experienced that.
You know,
you're doing maybe a seven or nine minute role,
which,
uh,
means,
grappling sparring for the uninitiated.
And a lot of times a year,
two,
three minutes in,
especially if you're rolling with someone good and you are exhausted,
totally exhausted and you got to figure out a way to get to a clinch and just,
okay,
let's
try to bring your heart rate down and try to do just enough to defend and keep
moving,
but not enough to totally tax out your muscles.
And also don't let your mind get into that panic state.
Like the breath is what controls that because if he can't breathe,
you're gonna Flake.
Yeah.
I remember,
um,
training with a guy who was like a real athletic guy,
very strong guy,
but he hadn't done Jujitsu before and so he was really excited to learn it and
just try to get into Jujitsu and you know,
he's in their sparring and he asked me to spar and I'm like,
okay,
all right.
You know,
uh,
how long have you doing it now?
He's like,
AH,
a couple of months and this now.
And I'm just getting into it.
I'm just starting to spar.
I'm like,
all right,
let's go.
And,
uh,
so we started,
I remember I got to position,
I like mounted him and I could feel him just full panic.
His body locked up.
And I remember I'd never felt,
because I'm not usually rolling with someone who's that inexperience,
so to do like a raw white belts,
only been doing it for a short period of time.
He really didn't know what to do and he was just locked up and I'm like,
just calm down.
Just breathe very,
you know,
it's not going to help you.
Like this is definitely going to hurt you.
You're going to,
you're going to get tapped out either way.
But if you,
if you breathe in,
you're going to be able to keep going and you're going to be able to learn.
And I'll just,
I'll,
I'll walk you through shit,
I'll tell you what to what to not do,
where to put yourself,
but this can't ever let that happen ever.
Even if you were going to lose,
even if you're,
you're,
you're going to get tapped out.
Don't ever let yourself freak.
He can't freak.
And in a real emergency,
let's say some type of straight over vacation where,
I mean maybe there's a lot more on the line than a trophy or a medal or you
know,
like your life ego in the class.
Yeah.
Like your life.
Um,
yeah,
no one to breathe and keep calm.
It's really,
really,
really important.
Very important.
Keep your mind clear,
but it takes a lot of practice and you have to do it.
And there's a lot of really cool breathing exercises that you can do.
Even just walking,
jogging,
you know,
even with your exercises and so forth,
everyone can lose anyone especially that's learning and developing.
You can lose and you're probably going to lose,
whether it's in sparring or whether it's in competition when you come up against
someone who's better than you.
But there's a big difference between losing and losing composure and breaking.
You know that that term breaking when you feel a guy give up.
We've all seen it.
We've seen it in fights and some guys just don't break.
Like here's a brief example.
Jon Jones doesn't break.
He just doesn't break.
You know,
he might take breathers.
He might,
but he is,
he is.
He in his mind,
he's the greatest of all time.
He's going to figure out how to beat you.
It's a foregone conclusion.
He's not going to tap.
Like when he fought Vitor Belfort,
Vitor Belfort caught him in a beautiful arm bar from the guard and had his arm
completely hyperextended ruined his arm.
I mean his arm,
John's arm was fucked up for like months afterwards.
He had to take a Gig on the ultimate fighter and coach for a long time because
he wasn't able to train and he wasn't,
he was not going to be able to fight for at least like six months to let that
arm heal.
But it didn't matter.
He was,
he was not going to tap like he was gonna get his arm broken and he was going to
still,
when he was gonna find a way to win,
he is not breaking.
And then there's other guys,
the first moment where things go wrong,
you see this look in their eye,
they were like,
oh shit,
it's going wrong.
They lose composure and like these,
these doors that you go into with your mind,
you get real comfortable entering these doors.
You get real comfortable entering these,
these areas of the mind.
And this can apply to all aspects of your life,
I think.
Well,
like Jack Hurray got,
you know,
when he fought a Roger that perfect example,
perfect example.
Did he wanted the win took the,
the damage to the elbow fought one arm just to eke out the,
the victory there was now.
But I think for folks who don't know what we're talking about,
Hodrick Gracie,
one of the very best black belts in the world and shock array,
one of the very best black belts in the world.
Was it in the Monday owls?
I think it was the open finals.
Yeah.
It was a huge two world championship and hydro broke Jocker Rey's arm and Jah
courageous tuck that sucker in his belt and kept going.
Kept going,
I don't know,
30 or 40 seconds.
So he just basically played outside edge of the mat because he had points.
Yeah,
he led them t he let them break his arm instead of table is crazy.
Now for your,
for your listeners out there though,
don't do that.
Don't do that.
We're talking about hardcore professional athletes that make their living
fighting world championships in the lime,
you know,
thousands of dollars in the line.
But in class.
Yeah.
Tom,
one of those guys that like,
Hey,
if you catch me,
you track me.
I,
you know,
fighting out of the arm walk or a triangle.
Look,
the mistake's already been made.
You got me in the trap.
I made a mistake.
I acknowledge it,
you know,
I mean a fight a little bit.
But you know,
as soon as I feel like,
ah Nah,
this is just tap,
it's just so good about it.
So important to tap.
The biggest mistakes I've ever made in training is not tapping,
especially when you're over 45 and these guys that are want to,
and that,
that brings up another subject.
Uh,
I've been really doing a lot of work with Jujitsu for a lifetime.
You know,
I,
I've,
I quit the grandsons of Elliot.
Gracie been saying,
you know,
let's get that video because you have a beautiful video that you sent me and
let's show what happened to Jack Arrays.
Obo Too,
by the way,
Jack,
he had surgery on his elbow and they pulled these chunks of,
of,
of bone that were broken off and cartilage inside his elbow.
I never heard about the aftermath.
I knew it was pretty messed up,
but I never heard exactly what he had to do to repair that.
He did.
It was bad.
Yeah,
he had it recently repaired,
had to repaired back then.
But the damage,
all the cartilage and all the stuff that's broken off inside of his elbow was
just swimming around in his elbow,
messing with his at some serious,
oh,
it's so painful.
You know,
you can't extend your arm all the way while your body builds up,
you know,
bone and calcification around that injury and you get those osteophytes and
before you know it,
you pretty much lose range of motion and your,
your joints,
the surgery,
uh,
images,
he put a online and it was just like so disgusting.
Bad News,
man.
I do love to avoid surgery.
Yeah.
He,
it was a five hour surgery just to clean out his elbow.
Look at this and it's a good chance a man that was really nasty,
but you know,
even after the surgery there's a good chance that never going to be the savvy
guy.
Very good chance.
I mean,
they're finding out ways now with stem cells to regenerate cartilage,
like for the first time ever,
football players are doing it.
They're using it on an older folk that have add bone to bone arthritis for
years.
It's pretty amazing,
isn't it?
What?
We're going to break time.
We're in a great time.
If we could just live long enough,
Joe.
Yeah,
just get me placing parts for everything grown from our own bodies,
right?
Yeah.
Well it's very possible that that is going to happen,
but also very possible that they're just going to be able to regenerate tissue,
that all your injured tissue,
all your damaged area,
so just going to be able to regenerate them.
It's going to be like star Trek,
right?
Where they used to take that little thing and then go over your body and you're
healed now.
Well,
there's a guy in Germany,
a doctor,
Peter Weller,
who is the same guy who created that Regena keen process that all the pro
athletes,
they were flying over to Germany for doing to do it and now they go to a,
there's a company called lifespan medicine that does it in Santa Monica and they
do in Dallas and I,
I believe they're opening up other offices as well.
They take your blood out,
they spin it in a centrifuge and the heat it up and the reaction to the heat
makes your blood produce this really intense anti inflammatory.
And I've had it done a lot.
A lot of people have had really chronic injuries,
had it done and it's works miracles.
Well,
he's developed this full body MRI machine,
which literally just get some map of everything going on in your body.
And once he went and did it,
he developed this and found out he had colon cancer.
Well,
yeah,
he had no idea.
A particularly tough,
aggressive type of colon cancer and caught it right away.
Hmm.
Early on went into surgery.
No it's fine.
But I mean it's like this is how amazing it is.
It's so amazing that it actually worked and benefited the guy who created it.
It's amazing.
Amazing Stash to be the beneficiary of your own inventions and discoveries,
ma'am.
Well it's,
it's also a reward for being on the cutting edge of healing and science for this
guy and the medical science.
But let's,
let's play this a video that you have that you sent us cause it's really cool.
I really a,
I liked what you do and it's really exciting to see and I want to talk to you
about it.
So we'll play that real quick.
I've spent almost a lifetime and take that when you aren't starting as a young
wrestler and once it was 10 years old,
always is in love with the whole concept of mescaline.
You laugh when you're on the ground.
Uh,
who's just one of the few things I was good at right from the beginning.
Jujitsu and surfing and tropical El Salvador.
I love it.
Okay.
So for folks who will just listening and not watching,
it's just Steve demonstrating a bunch of different Jujitsu techniques and uh,
now mobility training,
which is a,
a big part of what you do to keep healthy and keep your,
your,
your joints healthy and protect yourself from injuries.
Right?
Absolutely.
I mean,
if you think about it,
it's probably the most fun I got a two guys can have without,
without a woman,
man.
I mean,
yeah.
It's like rolling with your,
you know,
like wrestling on their living room for in your pajamas with your brother,
right?
It's like,
yeah.
Incredibly fun.
Great mental stimulation.
It's a fun game.
Very Fun.
As long as you can get over the tapping part w well,
what we were talking about earlier,
just it's like no one gets angry when someone shoots a ball in on them.
When you play basketball and there's the dates there,
let's pull those dates back so he could see what the dates are.
Tell everybody where they are is in the 22nd and March 28,
no,
go ahead.
I'm sorry.
It says 28th of November to the 5th of December,
and then the 5th of December to the 12th of December in 2015 so this is a start,
a new tradition that says this is a new thing that you're starting to do and uh,
what a great vacation.
You know,
have some fun.
Go to El Salvador,
do some surfing.
You guys have surf lessons,
you're going to teach Jujitsu.
Teach different ways of increasing your joint flexibility and preventing
injuries and just haven't got just how to stay with it for a lifetime.
And like for guys that want to just stick with what they love doing.
You wrote an article about it recently?
Well,
yeah.
I mean like most guys,
by the time they hit 40 or they're not going to be doing that anymore,
they're going to have to quit because they're going about it wrong.
And I was on that path myself.
I mean,
when I was in my mid forties I'd be getting up in the morning.
It was like,
oh my God,
I can barely turn around to back my car out of the garage.
And I'm thinking,
Geez,
what's what is going to be like in 10 years from now if I'm just in my mid
forties already suffering this pain and stiffness and inflammation.
So I started really investigating the different exercises,
systems,
mobility systems.
Of course I've always been interested in died,
you know,
experimenting and so forth.
And uh,
you know,
I've been doing this for a long time and I discovered a lot of really good
things.
I like to share with people so that you can continue to do what you love so we
can all be like master Elliot Gracie and you know,
95 years old.
I mean,
getting on the Mat and still having fun with it.
You know,
he was,
he was fanatical about his diet.
He was fanatical about his died.
But you know,
as you get older you have to be,
you got to,
you got to be more and more fanatical as the old aging process starts to set in.
When I was young,
I think I was just less aware of what was going on.
When I ate bad food.
I think it was just less aware.
Like I was like,
oh,
this tastes good.
What a great cheeseburger,
tastes awesome.
But I wasn't really,
I wasn't as conscious about the actual effects.
Whereas now I'm pretty aware of what kind of state my body's in.
Like very frustrating for me if I'm,
if my mind is an adult place,
like especially if I have to do interviews early in the morning and I just
haven't quite woken up yet and I'm having conversations in the words just aren't
coming out that good.
They're just clumsy and it's frustrating.
So I'm,
I'm pretty aware of like when I'm at my optimum state and I really notice now if
I eat crappy food,
I really notice if I,
if I have like something that's like got a lot of bread in it or something
that's just an unhealthy deep fried nonsense,
it just,
well,
it's two guys that do a lot of traveling and a,
you're,
you know,
you're doing shows all over the place besides UFC is,
uh,
sometimes it is pretty hard,
you know,
to find good,
good stuff.
But,
uh,
what,
I always pack my own stuff.
I always have like a,
I call it my Hobo bag.
It's a bag full of stuff.
I go from,
you know,
a fairies health food stores or whatever,
I showed up on,
you know,
good,
really good quality stuff.
Like what are you packing the Hobo bag of raw almonds.
I mean,
there's so many Kelly Oh,
places round now,
you know,
I'm not like a,
a total fanatic about Paleo,
but they do have some pretty damn good healthy stuff,
you know,
different bars and,
and,
and different concoctions that are already sealed pouches or,
you know,
different things like that.
I'll get a whole bunch of things like that.
Uh,
I love Carob pods.
Carob is just like fantastic.
It's like raw carrot right off the tree and,
um,
uh,
fresh fruit.
What is the,
what is a raw carrot bar look like?
Ah,
it's not a bar.
It's like a,
it looks like,
uh,
oh,
what do they call them via,
say,
Shia pods or whatever that you see in the ground sometimes it looks like that.
Yeah.
But it's sweet.
You just chew it and spit the seeds and it's absolutely delicious.
Good fiber.
Uh,
it's known as a blood sugar stabilizer so that you eat this thing,
man.
You're not hungry for hours.
So when you're on the road,
it's just a good way to keep yourself from,
from getting too hungry.
I don't think I've ever seen it before.
Um,
they're very popular.
It isn't there.
Let's Australia.
I used to get them in a,
yeah,
that's it.
Wow.
And very popular in this delicious.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
when,
when I was living,
um,
and uh,
uh,
Redondo beach area,
my girlfriend used to go to this place called rawsome.
It was like a raw foods place and they would sell them.
But my guide,
they were like a fucking arm and a leg man.
These things where like,
so crazy expensive.
And one day I was in a Marin County,
um,
can't remember the little town.
But anyway,
this is what backward in my camper van days.
I've got to get out and go to this little coffee shop to get a paper or
whatever.
And I'm seeing these things in the ground.
And I look up and there's a tree and it was like hundreds of them just laying
there,
man.
I got some plastic baggies,
you know,
and just,
you were sure that it was that.
Oh,
I tasted it.
Oh Wow.
It was like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
this is a carrot,
but it's a carob tree growing right here.
Pull the [inaudible] image rather,
and Marina County carob tree look like.
I don't think I've ever,
I really don't think I've ever seen that.
Like if I looked at that,
like that one looks like a bundle of snakes,
that third picture from the top,
but it was right there on the right.
It's,
it's,
uh,
I,
I was just utterly shocked because,
you know,
I had been paying a lot of money for these damn things and there they were just
like,
man,
I had no idea that they even grew in California.
How long does it last once you get it from the tree?
Does it go bad?
And Ron,
no,
they're like dried.
I mean,
is there like a dried pod that you could just keep for a long time?
Probably years.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Wow.
I mean they're really tasty.
It's really nice little sweet.
You know what it's like.
Um,
you know,
white sugar,
white granulated sugar is probably one of the worst things you can eat.
Toxic.
Yeah.
Toxic,
right.
But sugar cane actually,
you know,
like from the cane field actually has a lot of health benefit.
It doesn't really,
yeah.
It's,
it's sweet.
It has fiber,
it has a lot of nutrients,
minerals and so forth.
I mean obviously,
you know,
you don't eat a lot of it cause it's powerful stuff.
You know,
it's like one of those very powerful foods.
But the carob pods,
it kind of like the same thing.
If you do have a bit of a sweet tooth or you know,
whatever,
uh,
it's a fantastic way to,
to uh,
sate your sweet tooth and wow.
The fiber is amazing really.
I really was not aware at all.
I always thought of Carob is like something that you yeah,
like the process stuff like chocolate.
Yeah.
It's about as bad as chocolate.
The way they process isn't really.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
maybe a little less harsh on your system because a lot of people have a
chocolate sensitivities.
You know,
you always hear about gluten or dairy,
but man,
a lot of people have a lot of sensitivity to chocolate.
It's a lot of,
a lot of different things out there that had been overeating for years and years
and years that can give you food sensitivities.
Well,
some chocolate's really good,
right?
Like raw chocolate is very high and,
but some people are very sensitive to the,
uh,
acids.
Really fourth and chocolate.
And so there's this Caribbean then is,
how do you say it?
Cut Cow,
cow,
cow.
The raw chocolates,
the raw chocolate and that stuff is really good for you,
right?
Yeah,
it can be,
can be for some people it's like,
it's like it's powerful stuff and if you overeat anything,
you're going to develop a po potential,
uh,
sensitivity.
Yeah.
Um,
as I think gluten,
gluten in itself is not all that bad.
Right.
But Americans had been just eating it like crazy,
you know,
toast in the morning.
Uh,
you know,
we,
yeah,
it was cereal and then sandwich for lunch,
pasta for dinner,
dinner rolls and it's just like they're getting inundated.
Well like God,
you could probably develop a food sensitivity to anything if you probably you
could get eggs or chicken sensitivity or something if you just ate it,
you know,
three,
three square meals a day.
I'm pretty certain of that.
I went for a while more than six months where I just didn't touch any gluten.
I said,
let me see what happens.
One thing I lost weight.
I was pretty shocked at like how easy it was.
Like my body thinned out,
lost body fat,
my face got thinner.
Um,
I carry fat in my face.
I'm like one of those dudes,
I carry fat.
If I get fat,
love handles and I get it in my face.
I don't get it in my arms.
I don't get it in my legs,
but I get it my like around my belly and my sides and I get it at my face and
all that went wrong.
My fish shrunk down and my son,
I was like,
wow,
this is interesting.
It is interesting how the fat patterns just shrink up.
There's three major fat distributions,
right?
You got your depo fat.
That's like the love handles or with women and sometimes it's the saddlebags and
the side of the thigh.
Sometimes you'll see a women and the upper back or the tricep area with guys.
That's usually the La yeah,
or the belly or the love handles for most guys,
you know,
then you have internal fat.
That's the dangerous stuff.
They intra abdominal fat,
that gut fat,
that's what,
that's what can kill you.
Uh,
then you have subcutaneous fat.
It's like the smooth fat underneath the skin,
like a,
like an insulation layer.
And then of course they've identified that Brown fat also,
it's like a act of fat.
It produces heat in the body.
It's like part of the survival mechanism.
Back when our ancestors had to tolerate a lot of extremes in temperatures like
cold,
you have this brown fat,
it's like an metabolically active fat and uh,
it's,
it's kids have it,
but by the time you were like 12 and almost disappears because you know,
we have this,
uh,
regulated temperatures all the time.
People don't expose themselves to cold.
They're always bundling up and the homes are overheated.
But,
um,
but a lot of people were saying,
now you can actually get that metabolically active fat.
The brown fat Sal's gone,
which helps keep you ween and helps burn the other yellow fat.
So cold showers,
cold water treatments,
exposing yourself to cold,
a real good thing for develop that and uh,
the brown fat and build your immune system and you,
you have a much better tolerance to cold and much less likely to get a
innervated and cold weather.
So you don't have a tendency to come down with colds or flu and stuff like
really brown fat,
Brown fat.
I'd never heard of that before.
And what is it created by?
Like what it's in your,
uh,
some of it's in the peritoneal cavity,
some of it's a up in the neck,
uh,
area.
Uh,
and it's,
it's just something that nature provided to help temperature regulation,
helping tolerate cold.
So it was that like more common with Inuits and folks who live in real.
Yeah,
for sure.
They have well developed brown fat,
but you and I could do it too if we just expose yourself a little bit more to
the cold.
I have you done any cryotherapy if you've done any of that and not as uh,
as uh,
like the way it's been used.
How long are you in town for?
Uh,
let's see.
What am I going down to San Diego?
I'm the keynote speaker for that.
A strength matters summit.
That's a 20th through the 22nd march in San Diego.
17th 16th,
16th.
And I gotta take you to this place in La.
It's called Cryo healthcare.
I got to bring you down.
Love Coal.
This,
this is insane.
250 degrees below zero.
You go into like a meat locker.
I mean,
it is,
is crazy.
You put on a surgical mask,
you put on ear muffs,
you wear socks that go up to your like knee high socks and like those rubber
crocs cause you don't want to stand on the floor.
Yeah.
And you were also wearing gloves anywhere.
Underwear,
very important ladies and gentlemen.
And you don't want to have any moisture in your body.
You know,
ever want to go there.
Sweaty.
Yeah.
You go there for three minutes,
three minutes at 250 degrees below zero and it is cold as fuck.
And all I do is I just concentrate on staying calm and breathing and I breathed
and I count and that's what I do.
I go one,
two,
three and I try to count slower than a minute so that when they give you a timer
you have one minute remaining.
So when I count that minute down,
I always want to make sure that I'm not one,
two,
three,
four bucks.
I'm counting slower than the actual build up.
Do you like maybe start at 30 seconds and build up each time?
Or I did.
The first time they did it,
they put me in for two minutes and I said,
and they'd go,
well the first time,
do you want to try it?
You know,
don't go into long,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And I go,
okay,
how,
what's the longest I could do it?
And they said three minutes.
So I said,
all right,
well I'll try your two minutes.
I tried two minutes,
I think,
I think it will last another minute.
I go,
let's try another minute.
So then I went in again and I did three minutes and now what I do is I do three
minutes,
I take,
um,
maybe five,
six minutes off and I get on an elliptical machine and warm up and then I'll go
back in for another three minutes.
And it's amazing to me.
For years I did the,
uh,
the dousing.
It's a nice bath or bucket bit,
ah,
ice bucket challenge.
Well,
it's funny cause I had been doing this years and years before when I lived in
Philly.
I had a backyard that was pretty much secluded with a big wall so I could
basically,
you know,
strip down naked in my backyard and my neighbors couldn't see me.
And in the back corner I had this big Spec it and I had a five gallon bucket and
the all year long I would go and very slowly pour a five gallon bucket for
starting with the admin up over the head and down the back.
And the Russians that had taught me this said that it creates like this
artificial flash fever that is not quite the same thing with the shower,
which is more prolonged because you're doubting yourself with a sudden
immersion.
It's kind of like plunging into like a cold lake.
Uh,
it's supposedly burns up any bacteria or germs or whatever,
and your body.
All I know is that for the years I did it in Philadelphia,
15 years when I had,
when I was a householder,
I didn't get a cold.
Really.
I did not get a cold.
People around me would have flu,
they'd be sick.
And I was,
my immune system was like amazing.
Well,
the benefits of this cryo therapy as a,
it's been explained to me.
And if you go to Cryo health care.com,
I think it is,
I forget the website,
but the name of the place in La is cryo healthcare.
There's a bunch of different styles of these cryo machines.
One of them is from the neck down.
You stand in and your head is outside and you don't have to put anything on your
face.
I don't find that one to be as effective.
It's good.
Certainly better than nothing.
Um,
but the one we stepped into,
the meat locker,
God,
that's a motherfucker.
They're going to have one of those down the street and Woodland Hills,
um,
down the road a bit.
They're going to be putting out one of those within the next month or so.
But that would certainly stimulate brown fat.
Oh,
with that thing.
So this is,
this is the,
see the meat locker one is the one on the left.
See,
they have that one.
That one's fairly common kind of nationwide.
That one,
the one that you see on the left,
the meat locker.
That's the mother fuck that way,
man.
Whew.
I'm going to take you there.
I say claustrophobic and that way,
right?
No,
it's not claustrophobic.
You developed the door easy.
Yeah.
The little one just goes to like,
I don't know man.
The little one's easy.
The little one's so easy.
It's not,
it's just not the little ones hard.
If you've never done it before,
you go,
oh Jesus.
But if you've done it,
um,
the,
the big one is like the little one.
That's that one right there.
You just Kinda,
you climb out of it,
you're fine.
But the uh,
the big one has this amazing effect.
You get out of there,
you feel like you could jump over buildings.
He like,
whoa.
Once your body,
like realizes that you're not going to die,
no one has dropped you in the top of the moon and it's on a hundred really,
250 degrees below zero.
That's literally the surface of the moon is 250 degrees below zero.
Yeah.
In the dark.
The moon varies from like 250 degrees to 250 degrees below zero depending on
whether or not the sun is hitting you or whether or not you're in the shade.
Well that's like how all these things where even even training,
right?
You know,
your body,
if training's done properly,
your body perceives it as a threat to its survival.
You basically are tapping into your survival mechanism with these things and
your body in its wisdom will say,
Hey,
I'm not quite up to snuff here.
I better adapt and get stronger so I don't die.
Yeah.
And that,
that's training to weight training or,
or anything,
you know,
you,
you have to make it a stimulating enough and difficult enough to tap into that
survival mechanism so that if you're not,
you're not getting the benefit of the training.
Or in this case they cry a therapist.
So your body like an adaptation response.
Well this is this new system that they're,
they've developed in Japan.
It's called Kaatsu.
And uh,
I don't know the gentleman's name of created it,
but I had a chance to try it out this weekend in Austin.
And what essentially is,
is like these,
they take these straps and they constrict the outs like your,
your Bicep,
like right below the,
uh,
the delts.
And then you go through like a 15 minute routine,
like 15 minutes of you do curls,
you start off,
you do pushups,
you do curls with a kettle bell to failure.
And all this is while your blood flow is restricted.
And then you do like a ropes and you do sets of three for 15 minutes.
By the end of the 15 minutes,
you're fucking arms are dead.
I mean,
yeah,
cause you're restricting the blood flow and then they release it and take it
off.
And apparently the response that your body has to the fact that your blood flow
is restricted,
it triggers all sorts of,
of responses as far as your growth hormone,
your testosterone,
all these different,
you be,
your body starts trying to compensate for the fact that it doesn't have enough
blood flow.
So it just over ramps everything up and it's apparently fantastic for healing.
It's fantastic for people that have injuries.
Recovery time from injuries reduces drastically like a Bodie Miller.
The,
uh,
the Olympic skier.
Um,
he uh,
used it to get back in shape from a surgery like much quicker than he would have
without it.
That's just one,
one,
one of these new methods,
much like this cryo thing,
much like many of these other protocols where they're trying to figure out ways
to kind of trick your body into ramping up the healing process are ramping up
the,
so it's used for healing not for,
is trying to try any person for both for both was just been curious.
It'd be interesting to see how it compares to just traditional strength training
as far as you know,
actual general strain.
Yeah.
And the idea also is that it puts a strong load on your muscles but not on your
joints because everything you're doing like say if you're doing like kettle bell
curls to failure.
I was doing it with like a 35 pound kettle bell with two hands.
That's not a lot of weight.
Now it's not a lot of weight and just you're just cranking out reps,
but because your biceps are tied off at the top,
he's just getting that blood crazy pumped and trapped up and to the ends of the
muscles.
Yeah,
your arms just flows.
We restrict it.
I get,
yeah,
they grow dry.
They look giant.
Like your arms are giant.
It's painful,
it's painful.
But I just fucked around with it yesterday for the first time and apparently the
results are amazing and a ad on it.
We're starting to look into this and trying to,
you know,
see what we could do with it to bring this to the mainstream,
but to try to get more athletes involved doing things like this.
We kind of get these,
you get these results where you start going,
oh,
okay,
well if you do that and this,
what if you do cryotherapy and this Kaatsu method and also the breathing also
that like what are,
what are the,
what's the,
the difference in the response to your body?
Like what's the difference in how quickly you can heal,
how quickly you can get in shape.
And that's a big issue for MMA fighters is the downtime from injury and then
ramping your body back up to competition shape afterwards.
You could tell,
I mean anybody who's ever gotten to a very good fitness level and then got
injured,
it's so frustrating getting back to the gym and then trying to get back in
shape.
I said a lot of guys never,
never do get back because it's just such a hard row.
Uh,
such a hard road to,
to come back on.
It's hard for people to accept the state that they're in.
You know,
like especially that's one of the issues with younger athletes.
you're young,
you're 20,
your body heals quick,
you're just a wild motherfucker and your,
he'd doing anything you want your rank list and as you get older,
it's one of the things that I liked about your article that you wrote.
You have to be smarter.
You have to recognize that your body's going to take longer to heal.
You can't be reckless with it.
And also you really should probably shouldn't have been reckless with it when
you were 20.
But you could,
you could get away with it to a certain extent.
Now that you're older,
you have to be wiser.
You know,
everyone thinks they're bulletproof and they're going to last forever.
you just can't even imagine.
I can remember going to a wrestling tournament.
It was in York,
Pennsylvania.
It was like,
I used to do the summer wrestle freestyle wrestling circuit.
They used to have tournaments all over Pennsylvania.
And I remember meeting a guy that was like 33 years old and I was just blown
away.
My God,
you're still wrestling you 33 Oh man,
you're my new hero.
I can't believe it.
I want to be just like you went.
And I just couldn't believe.
I thought this guy was like ancient in was probably like 19 at the time.
And I could not believe that this guy was in there wrestling as well as he did
at 33.
That's that funny.
Now you'd kill it.
Do anything to get the 32 year old body man,
42 year old.
I was like,
still fantastic,
you know,
still feeling great.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
as my grandfather said,
no one gets out of here alive.
You're,
you know,
father time will take its toll over time,
no matter what you're doing,
no matter how many therapies and so forth,
you know,
but you tried to do your best with what she got and you do try to preserve your
youth and your vitality.
But one,
one of the major problems I see,
especially an extremist sports like Jujitsu or MMA or whatever,
uh,
is the overtraining.
Everyone thinks more is better and it's not better's better,
but more is not better.
That's a huge issue with rustling.
Oh,
terrible.
Wrestlers may are notoriously the most overtrained group of athletes there are,
I think.
But isn't that training with the overtraining?
Doesn't that develop this insane mental toughness that wrestlers are known for?
That's part of it.
The mental toughness is,
is,
is a huge part of it because that is a hard ass sport.
Did you happen to see the,
uh,
the uh,
Foxcatcher the movie?
Yes,
I did.
And that,
uh,
it wasn't exactly accurate at all.
No.
Mark Schultz put up actually a thing on his Facebook page,
all the accuracies.
Okay.
That are in that movie.
And they're pretty substantial.
Pretty substantial.
Yeah.
It's,
it's really,
it's actually frustrating and annoying.
The guy's alive.
He's an Olympic gold medalist world champion,
one of the best wrestlers,
really pretty much ever,
ever.
And they,
they portrayed him in a very inaccurate light.
Pretty much so.
Yeah.
I mean,
they made him look like a dumb jock.
The guy's brilliant.
The guy was brilliant and a very articulate,
very smart guy.
And um,
my college wrestling coach was the junior coach there.
Foxcatcher rule.
Yeah.
Dale bonds.
Well,
he's in the college,
so he was a NCAA coaches hall of fame.
Uh,
so this was
after you were in college visit?
After I graduated from college,
I was still living in Philly and you know,
Dale used to invite me to come on down and a train now and again.
And I,
I took him up on a couple of times.
Unfortunately it was just a little bit too far away to be driving,
you know,
I had a day job.
Wrestling is one of those sports that,
uh,
you pretty much have to have your mid afternoons open cause that's when all the
universities train and that's when most guys train.
So I was really,
you know,
Jones if for some grappling experience,
but it was really hard working at job and at that time I was married and it
hauls holder with a family and all that.
But I think you're down a few times and I got a chance to tour the facility and
it was really impressive and a headache clinic with,
um,
well the guy they didn't even mention was that guy a Valentine Jordan,
the Bulgarian guy.
That's the guy that,
uh,
dupont,
gave his whole fortune two when he died,
his fortune went to the,
uh,
this Bulgarian,
coach reels that fuck yeah,
the,
the family's still fighting it.
There's still contesting it to this day.
Wow.
Yeah.
He really liked this guy.
And so I had a,
I had a couple of clinics with that guy,
one at Drexel and uh,
cause he,
you know,
he's making his way around the different colleges and learned a lot of awesome
exercises.
And conditioning and wrestling.
And of course I met the great day of shoulds,
had a clinic with him.
It's like wow.
He was definitely one of America's finest wrestlers ever.
But even more than his physical skills was as his mental skills.
He,
he just had an amazing mind and I was really fortunate to have,
you know,
been able to travel in those type of circles and get a chance to see it.
But this is after my,
my,
uh,
college wrestling days.
So I was looking for that thing to fill the gap,
you know?
And that's when I discovered this Gracie brothers,
you know,
around 1989 man,
it was like,
Oh shit,
this is what I been walking for a man.
What is it about the Bulgarians?
A lot of the Russians and you know,
there's a lot of those people from that part of the world that has such good
athletes.
There's so many tough people from that part of the world.
Like,
what is that?
Well,
you know,
a lot of our best fighters come from the poorer sections of America.
You know,
kids come up in the projects and you know,
some of these inner city kids,
you know,
look at,
uh,
like in Philly or Detroit or Mandy gets him tough kids.
They grew up scrapping and it builds a mental toughness sometimes,
you know,
like a Mike Tyson growing up where,
where he did and a hell's kitchen up there in New York.
I mean Brownsville ox or Brownsville.
Yeah.
So I mean those guys are just,
you know,
they,
they grow up in a really tough neighborhood.
It's kind of like dog eat dog and it produces like a really tough kind of minded
person.
And I think a lot of these eastern European countries,
you know,
they don't have much and you know,
they,
uh,
they have a lot of time in their hands.
There's not a lot to do for the kids.
And you know,
they end
up like most boys,
you know,
getting into trouble and fighting and doing all this kind of crazy stuff.
I think that's one of the reasons why,
uh,
this new urban playground gymnastics kind of stuffed at the guys are doing,
it's become so popular because I mean,
you know,
that's pretty available.
It's just equipment.
Just sitting there cost very little to put it in.
Did we play that video of you there?
Last time we were here with the Wa with the bar stars,
that was pretty cool.
Pretty cool man.
But in eastern Europe that stuff's really popular,
you know?
And um,
so yeah,
they don't have a lot to do.
They don't have the same kind of uh,
basketball courts that we do and they,
they don't have the facilities all the times,
but wrestling is pretty cheap,
man.
You know,
you know,
it doesn't take a lot of equipment,
anybody just wrestling really.
There's a lot of boxers right now that are coming out of the bar,
the world as well.
Sure.
I mean a surrogate cove Kovalev of you have seen him fight before?
I have not.
I've heard the name,
but I,
I haven't had the opportunity to actually see him.
He's a motherfucker around.
It can be Bernard Hopkins.
And then he just beat John Pascale the other night.
And man,
it's amazing.
It's such amazing good fighter.
The way he moves.
I mean,
he really makes boxing exciting again.
He's a killer.
Just goes for the kill,
like constantly,
but super technical,
like everything about his movement.
It's very technical.
It's foot work is his ditzes distancing the economy of his movements,
the way throws punches.
Just beautiful,
beautiful to watch.
But there's so many tough guys,
canonical off skin,
all these tough,
tough guys coming out of Russia of that area.
You know,
that part of the world is so former Soviet Union.
Well,
I've traveled like into Siberia.
I've,
I,
I traveled Jill,
like,
uh,
you know,
Dan around the Black Sea area.
I've been to a lot of the Slavic countries too.
You know,
Serbia and Slovenia and man,
the gods are huge big strapping guys and you just don't see the obesity either.
Man.
They don't have the food,
you know,
they can't afford just to overeat like we do in America or you know,
and uh,
the rest of Europe or the UK or whatever.
Uh,
you see some,
you know,
some real fatties,
but man,
when you're there,
wow,
people are pretty pretty lean and wiring and stringy and a lot of the younger
guys are just like specimens.
I don't know whether it's genetics or it has to be,
I mean you think about the people that have lived and gotten through those harsh
climates and tough jobs and just had to work survival of the fittest and that's,
those are the people that bread and those are the people that kept going.
We what you notice also about a lot of those people from that part of the world
it,
which is interesting enough was not just that they're tough,
but they're very technical.
There's a lot of really technical wrestling that comes out of Russia and a out
of the former Soviet Union,
that area,
like those guys,
those Russian nationals that went up to Montreal,
that's a lot of weird.
George Saint Pierre learned how to wrestle,
never wrestled in high school,
never rested on college,
but became one of the best wrestlers in MMA.
And that's part of the reason why
I remember I wrestled a bear this in the 70s,
arrested in the Montreal open wrestling tournament.
And this is just a,
at that time when the Russians were making a big influx in,
you know,
they were starting to charge to a defect and flee to the Western world,
the Soviet Union,
it was still existed.
And I remember our wrestled Victor Silberman in the finals and got my ass handed
to me,
man.
And so I was trying to talk to him later because I was really impressed with
this guy,
his technique and his skill and everything.
And uh,
I,
I was utterly shocked when he told me the only lifted weights once a week.
He lifted weights four times a month.
And at that,
how is that even possible?
I thought these Russian guys like lifted weights every day,
twice a day.
And he says,
no,
no.
We practice technical wrestling is the base of our training.
And then I was utterly shocked.
Um,
I had,
uh,
a guy that was trained with me in Philly for a while.
It's five times the Ukrainian national wrestling champion.
You used to be on the national team.
This was back when the Ukraine and Russia is all part of the Soviet Union and he
was telling me that,
um,
they would only spar really hardly twice a week because they found that the live
wrestling was what was producing all the injuries.
But when they would train,
they would train like real slow motion and they be gradually built their speed
to the point where they were just going all out horn and they would just do this
for long periods of time and wow.
It is unbelievably hard workout when you're shooting high crotch singles,
doubles and so forth at match speed over and over and over and over.
It's like Holy Shit.
And that was their main cardio.
It takes real discipline to that discipline,
man.
Most people that's in Jujitsu as well.
It's very similar.
A lot of your sentence want to roll,
just want to roll.
You don't want to go over drills,
but they never get technical.
That's the problem.
That is the problem.
Yeah.
Drills or where you really learn how to have those movements become a part of
your nervous system.
And then he,
you know,
and,
and keeping the sparring limited,
uh,
you,
you don't get your muscles and joints is stressed and you don't get the
injuries.
But I was very surprised to hear that,
uh,
you know,
cause I had a complete different,
uh,
perception because American wrestling,
he just basically pounding each other every time you go into the wrestling room,
you know,
it's just,
yeah.
That is the problem with,
uh,
do,
do the American produce amazingly tough wrestlers of course.
But the reason I think why we're not seeing,
uh,
Americans dominating the international scene anymore,
it's like there's no damn money at it,
man.
You know,
you,
you graduate from college and you know,
maybe you have a degree or whatever,
but what are you going to do with your wrestling skills?
MMA,
the UFC opened up a whole new,
you know,
a whole new door for former NCAA wrestlers.
Why the hell would he go and go to the Olympics and make peanuts when you can
make fairly decent money?
Possibly if you're good,
you
know,
if you're tough.
God,
yeah,
that's what I wanted to know.
Do the Russians have that same issue with overtraining during the no.
No,
because they don't spar.
Uh,
uh,
as much as the Americans do that,
they are very careful not to over train as they,
you know,
they,
they have like blocks where they kind of,
you know,
they kind of amp ramp up the training as they get near a narrow like world
championships or the Olympics or whatever.
Some people call it periodization or whatever,
but they,
they're very careful not to overtrain and over overdo it.
Well,
how come?
they're known for their mental toughness as well.
Like why does,
why don't the American wrestlers incorporate that into their workouts?
Or have they started to do,
they probably are,
you know,
I've lost a little bit of touch with the wrestling community,
but you know,
our wrestling coaches are fantastic.
You know,
the smart guy.
So I'm sure they're taking a hard look because the Russians have been really
successful as have the Iranians as the Turks,
the Bulgarians,
you know,
all of these countries that perennially put out like world champions,
Azerbaijan,
you know,
uh,
the Mongolians are really starting to dominate a judo and they,
you know,
they've always been tough as shit and wrestling.
So I think that,
uh,
for sure you can learn a lot from their,
their basic programs that are pretty simple programs really.
They're,
they're,
they don't have a lot of sophisticated equipment and so forth,
but what they meant,
they make up,
they make up for a lack of sophistication with equipment and facilities and all
that with technique.
They're real technicians.
That is the most important part of any martial art.
The most important part is having that technique down to just a razor sharpness
or razor sharpness.
Man.
You've got to hone those skills because you know,
a MMA,
Jiu Jitsu,
judo,
wrestling,
it's all technique.
I really wish you'd watch this past weekend,
this UFC because a man,
I'm going to have to catch it on the replay now.
You got to watch Anthony Pettis versus Hofeld dos Anjos there must have been
hell of a match.
Ooh.
Dos Anjos beat the brakes off of the Internet yet.
Okay.
How long did they wait to before they were loaded it up?
I mean,
what site do you go to to,
to uh,
fight,
fight pass.
UFC fight pass.
Yeah.
It's,
I dunno,
I don't believe it's up yet.
Okay.
And I'll check.
I don't think it is.
I mean,
you don't know what's on paper view.
It might be available on fight pass.
Okay.
Yeah,
I was just curious how long,
but I'll,
I'll go.
I'll definitely give it a check.
Fipass F has pretty much everything.
Um,
but I don't know how,
I think they do show some pay per views.
They have live events.
Hey,
why don't you,
why don't you bring their cup of,
I'm going to run the men's room real quick.
I'll be right back on just one sec.
Go ahead.
I'll try to find it.
We'll see if we could find some highlights of it.
But,
uh,
what I'm going to ask Steve about it after he gets done using the little girl's
real,
um,
uh,
w w what was incredibly impressive was not just the skill level the doe Sandra
showed,
but the,
the pace and the fitness and Steve,
uh,
he doesn't want to toot his own horn,
saw two towards the other room.
He's like,
he's so
knowledgeable.
And he got Diego Sanchez and did probably the best shape of his life when Diego,
uh,
challenged Bj Penn for the belt and Diego wound up getting beaten pretty badly
by Bj when PJ was in his prime BJ's like an all time great.
And I'm just,
uh,
one of my all time favorite fighters,
but he was in incredible shape for this fight as well,
which was always like kind of his Achilles heel was his,
uh,
he was so talented,
but he just never really
was able to continue that sort of strength and conditioning program that got
them into the shape that he was when he fought Diego Sanchez.
And what we were talking about with Steve,
um,
being that the technique is so important,
it is so incredibly important,
but MMA is so unbelievably grueling.
Yeah.
I had a conversation with shale sign about it who's a former UFC fighter and
he's fought for the title several times,
a great fighter and also a very open guy,
very open as far as like his own limitations and his strengths and weaknesses.
And he was just talking about how the time that you spend inside the octagon,
the competing for 25 minutes is almost impossible to really do.
It's almost too much time.
Um,
what I was saying was that Steve's back what I was saying,
that the amount of time that you spend in the octagon fighting in a championship
fight is so insane.
Like it's almost like you're sprinting for 25 minutes.
It's brutal.
And very few people figure out how to get in the right shape as well as work
their skills.
And there's that weird
man because like endurance is a skill,
but then there's also the skill of making the other guy use up his energy more
than yourself.
And I mean that.
Enter the,
you know,
uh,
controlling and,
and managing your energy system and the rang and on the mat as such a skill unto
itself.
I mean,
not,
let's just take out the striking skills and the grappling skills and all that
stuff.
Just that energy management,
that's huge man.
And a lot of guys don't pay enough attention to it.
I think,
well,
dealing
with pressure is a big one.
I remember from my days of competing that when guys like really aggressive and I
was backing up a lot of trying to move away,
I'd get so much more tired because you're always thinking,
you're thinking,
you're dealing with this guy attacking you and you're backing up,
which is kind of an unnatural movement.
I mean a lot of people run,
but very few people run backwards and you've got to realize that when you're
going backwards,
you're kind of using your muscles in a different way is different.
Yeah.
And very few people do like Muhammad Ali's to run miles backwards because he was
always backing up and then moving forward,
backing up and moving forward.
And one of the most beautiful things about him when you watch him,
like in his prime,
like the Cleveland Big Cat Williams days before,
uh,
they took his title the way because he didn't want to fight in the Vietnam War.
His footwork and movement was just magical and his ability to back up and be you
will,
you really couldn't catch him.
He was just backing up and moving forward,
backing up and moving forward.
And that's something he had to work at really hard.
But three minutes in a boxing match is so much different than five minutes with
wrestling and leg kicks and elbows and the clench and God,
it's one of the,
so I'm,
I'm curious to see what you think after you watch this fight because one of the
most impressive things about the fight as far as dos Anjos performance was his
cardio was insane.
There's just like something else,
man.
I mean,
he just attacked from the moment the,
the fight started.
He just went after us and just never let up.
Like literally never went up,
let up.
It was amazing.
It really was amazing.
Here's a,
here's a maybe a sore point,
uh,
but what do you think about the,
the use of the,
uh,
performance enhancing like stimulants took mask fatigue and so forth,
like,
which kinds you can do in another sales,
legal,
many different ones these days.
I'm just curious,
how are they testing for this stuff now?
Uh,
you know,
are the,
are these guys using like,
uh,
various stimulants to keep them like really pretty much hopped up while they're
protesting for everything?
Everything.
So guys are getting popped for a lot of different stuff.
Okay.
Hector lumbar discussed this district strict testing now,
especially California.
I mean I've given this guy credit but I give him credit again.
Andy fosters been the director of the California State Athletic Commission for a
few think a couple of years now.
But um,
he's a former fighter,
longtime martial artist and he's very smart,
very diligent about this.
And I've had some,
I had a conversation with them when the UFC was in Los Angeles and uh,
one of the things that he said,
he goes,
first of all,
we're going to test everybody tonight.
We're not just testing the,
the guys in the main event.
We're not just testing,
you know,
the,
the people that are involved in the paper view,
we're testing everyone that competes tonight,
blood and urine.
You're in before the fight,
blood after the fantastic.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's so cute.
I wish they'd do that for a regular Jujitsu.
Although it's probably cost prohibitive.
It's very cost prohibitive.
It's like $40,000.
I mean,
depending on what lab you go to,
I'm sure the results vary or the price varies,
but,
well,
at least the place winners,
you know the first uh,
yeah [inaudible] on the podium.
He needs to have to be tested,
man.
Yeah,
for Jujitsu,
Jujitsu does have a real epidemic in it.
It's a,
it's a real issue.
And unfortunately a lot of Jujitsu guys that have come over to MMA of pissed hot
too.
Um,
what's a good strength is so it's such a critical factor in,
in forcing positions,
you know,
I mean the technique is everything for sure.
But strength endurance ma'am,
it's God damn huge.
And there's some guys,
we all know,
some guys you try to hit singles on them,
you try to like try to do an arm drag and it's like trying to pull a wall.
You some dude's like,
look at who some are.
Paul Horace is a perfect example.
That damn dude is so strong.
He's so ridiculously strong.
You see guys like John Fitch tangled up with them and John Fetches in elite
wrestler elite took him down and cranked on his leg in the first round.
I mean,
John Never got out of the round.
He just couldn't,
couldn't get out of the round.
All of sudden he's leg locked and just didn't know what to do and got his,
got his leg hyper extended.
But these um,
uh,
performance enhancing drugs,
they're catching guys for some of them I've never even heard of.
Oh,
they're getting so sophisticated and stuff now there's so many new cocktails
that fall kind of just within the borders of legality,
you know.
Well that's what paper always discovering some new way to hop up or,
you know,
I mean,
I was just curious about your take,
you know,
because you're around these guys all the time,
so,
well,
I think there's a lot of guys that are taking things,
um,
when they don't think they're going to get tested,
you know,
when they need to for the training and just to get through it.
Yeah.
The training and also to recover from injury.
So that's a big one.
And not just injuries that you know about like surgeries,
but almost everybody is tweaked.
You got to have a bum knee or your elbow is bothering you or something's going
on with your neck.
Everybody.
There's almost no way of avoiding.
No.
Yeah,
exactly.
You cannot engage in an extremist sport like MMA and maybe to a lesser extent at
Jujitsu and judo and wrestling at that competitive level without the tweaks.
Yeah.
I don't think there's a way impossible.
You cannot do a combat sport without paying the price to the,
to the body,
but I wonder if a protocol will eventually be a stab.
I was like the most intelligent protocol,
similar to what you're getting with these Russians that are there,
that are developing,
they've developed this program for wrestling where they're just doing a lot of
technical training,
not nearly as much sparring,
but a lot of technique,
a lot of repetition and drills.
I wonder if that will slowly work its way into MMA and be established as this is
the way to do it,
the way they're doing it.
Saying Russia.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I think he's going to have to at some point because you know,
the career window for a lot of these guys right now is like,
what would you say,
like two years maybe.
Well,
nine years seems to be the magic number for everybody that seems like that,
right?
Yeah.
But don't you see a lot of these guys pretty much burning out within about a two
and a half,
three years?
It seems like there's a Lotta guys that flare to the top and then they're gone.
Yeah.
There's also the issue with their,
they're kind of forced to keep competing on a regular basis.
Once they become successful,
especially you break into the top 10 and you want to keep competing and winning.
And so you win a big fight and say,
okay,
we're with the UFC calls you up on Monday,
Hey,
we got blah,
blah,
and four months.
And you're like,
fuck.
Okay.
And you think,
you know,
man,
I would really love to rest this knee.
I'd really love to,
you know,
uh,
get some therapy on,
you know,
this elbow or whatever,
whatever issues you have.
And oftentimes that's not an option.
They have to go right back into training camp and these injuries become chronic
and it's a brutal way to make it live in man.
It's a very brutal way to make a living.
And some guys,
I don't know how Randy coture did it.
I don't know either.
He got through and it was late forties would no surgeries.
Of course he was an anomaly.
Me,
uh,
he,
I mean he was like,
uh,
I mean one out of thousands and thousands,
you know,
you just don't find guys like him.
Yeah.
I don't know how the hell he did it.
I mean,
I really have no idea.
It's,
it's incredible.
I wonder if he's suffering now at all.
Do you know him personally?
I do know him personally,
but he seems fine.
Is He?
Yeah.
Just follow a dementia or anything?
No,
he was just interviewed recently.
Um,
he,
uh,
was walking down the street with a girl who looked like she was about 20 years
old and he's got to be about 50.
She looked like,
uh,
like she just hopped off a porn set,
put on a tee shirt and uh,
it's treading down the road,
Captain America.
Wow.
Man.
As,
as my Australian friends,
I say,
good on you,
mate.
Good on you mate.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
He,
um,
I mean,
he seems fine,
but the point being that they asked him questions about Laila Ali,
uh,
you know,
Leila all leaves,
saying that she wants to fight Ronda Rousey.
I heard that little flap a doodle about that stuff.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's just because,
uh,
you know,
like,
what am I,
what am I here?
What I was was of course,
the Great Dan Gable,
like one of the greatest wrestlers,
not just in America,
but the world has ever produced,
man is a man,
and he went through the,
the Munich Olympics.
What year was that?
There was like 72.
Was it Muni Columbia?
Was that money?
Six 76 was where was in Los Angeles to 76.
Was that 88?
I don't remember.
It was the Munich Olympics.
It was that,
it was soul right.
Where they had that tragic.
Right,
right,
right.
But the,
uh,
the terrorists,
but anyway,
he walked through that tournament.
I'm scored on how is that even possible at the elite level,
not to be scored on incredible Jesus.
It's like,
wow,
I don't think anyone's ever done it before.
Since now.
He was an Uber dedicated monster honoring God,
man.
But wow.
Double hip replacement.
I don't know whether he's had knee replacement,
but I saw a video of the poor guy,
man.
I mean,
I,
I suppose if you'd ask him,
was it worth it?
He'd probably say,
hell yeah,
you mount the Cory.
But I,
his mind is fine.
It just looks like he's in such utter pain the way shuffles and,
and move it around.
He just beat himself to death basically with those crazy marathon training.
And that's one of the problems with the other young guys.
He was the role model for a lot of us young guys coming up.
And you know,
that that approach,
that kamikaze approach to training,
it really ages the body.
Yeah,
it really does.
When you're in your 20s,
you're not seeing the big picture man.
You know,
you gotta live with that body for,
you know,
a good number of years after you hang up your wrestling shoes.
Yeah.
And I think what you said,
like if you asked him,
he probably would say it was worth it because he,
you can't take away history.
I mean,
that guy has amazing memories of being one of the greatest wrestlers ever.
But his mind is okay,
at least.
Yeah.
He's a very intelligent guy,
but it doesn't have dementia or anything that you've sent in wrestling.
You're not taking that,
uh,
the,
the brain trauma.
Yeah.
Mark Coleman first ever UFC heavyweight champion.
His body is starting to fail him.
He had one hip replacement and apparently they have to replace it again.
He had a massive infection when they went in to look at it and he's in the
hospital now and there's a go fund me.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll retweet the link later today after this podcast is all are for folks who
want to help out mark.
But,
uh,
he,
um,
you know,
his,
his body is just all banged up from the years of wrestling,
high level wrestler.
And then from there all the years of competing in MMA,
he's,
he's getting his hip replaced.
Two is I believe both of them need to be replaced.
So that brings us back then full circle to where we started with the,
uh,
you know,
just to,
for a lifetime.
I really do believe there is a way that you can train and have a lot of fun with
this stuff,
but you got to keep it really light.
You know,
like the,
like,
uh,
the,
the grandson's Abelia Gracie,
keep it playful,
keep it fun,
don't be so concerned about points.
I mean,
some guys will bleed from the eyes not to have the guard pass.
It's like,
dude,
it's not even a tournament.
And you're getting cranked up in your neck and,
and,
and you're taking all this abuse for what?
Right.
But you got to be passed and then work on reclaiming,
reclaiming guard and just get good at the fence.
Like A,
like a Master Leo,
you know,
he was a master at defense man.
He couldn't do anything to the old man.
And that's one of the things in Hixson always preaches.
Like defense is the most important thing.
Most important thing is defense.
Be Safe,
basically safe and,
and I think he can extend your grappling career wound to advanced stage.
I think of all the martial arts,
you can pretty much do Jujitsu and submission.
Wrestling if you're,
if you're smart,
well under advanced age,
unlike a lot of other things.
Well,
it's ironic that you say that because Hixon himself is very banged up,
like really badly banged up.
He has eight herniated discs.
His,
uh,
he's got a lot of muscle atrophy.
Look,
if you look at his body,
he's got a lot of,
a lot of pain and suffering and uh,
he talked about it pretty openly when it was on the podcast and then afterwards
we discussed it.
I mean,
he doesn't look physically anything like he looked like back when he fought
quite a specimen.
Oh yeah,
man,
it was 200 plus pounds.
Very thick muscled and just flexible.
And his movement was amazing,
but all those years of getting cranked and also constantly training constantly
in their car and being slammed a lot.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
you can see in some of the old videos where he's getting smashed down to the
ground pretty hard.
That Zillow fight.
Yeah.
It was basically thrown himself backwards and the top up and,
but I mean that's a big heavy guy.
And I mean that wasn't just that.
It's like you said,
it's the training for that stuff.
Yeah.
It's ironic when you think about him being one of the masters and one of the
real originators of that whole breathing system,
you know,
he brought that yoga breathing,
that fire breathing to,
uh,
to the practice of Jujitsu.
And here he's all just really banged up.
You really can't train anymore.
I mean,
he kinda like goes over a technique and I think maybe he does some really,
really light rolling with people he knows perhaps.
But when it happens to everyone eventually,
yeah.
I'm very picky myself now.
I'm in my sixties it's like a Nixon's 10 years younger than you.
Yeah.
And probably the consensus all time.
Great.
All time.
Yeah.
If you ask people like,
who's the best Jujitsu and you know,
he,
he's a guy that tap Mark Schultz.
I asked him about that on the podcast a,
him and Mark Schultz,
like Mark Schultz had never really rolled with the Jujitsu black belt before.
And he said the guy was incredible grappler,
incredible coppler but Hixon caught him like in like 30 seconds with a triangle.
Like you just had no idea what it was.
You know,
he really didn't know what he was doing as most wrestlers,
especially at the time.
Most wrestlers now I would imagine it like six months.
Yeah.
Well being,
one of the things that mark was,
I'm disqualified for him.
One of his key matches was he,
uh,
got a guy in that Komora and used it to,
used it in a way that's illegal and wrestling and he would use it all the time
like that and MMA.
But he locked it up and rolled the guy within,
just ripped his shoulder apart.
Ouch.
I think it was the guy was from Turkey.
Um,
pull,
pull up the video,
see Mark Schultz,
disqualified wrestling,
but it's a classic,
a double risk lock.
You don't catch wrestling,
double risk.
And he uses it to flip the guy over and just destroys his arm in the process.
And he went on to learn a lot of submission techniques.
The guy was an absolute frightening animal towards then resonate after he
learned this as emissions.
So physically strong too.
And a lot of the early catches catch can wrestling submissions were all part of
it.
I'm reading this fascinating book.
Let me get the exact title here.
Um,
uh,
right now one of it's the history of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and this guy did an
amazing job.
I'm putting this,
putting this thing together.
I don't know,
I don't have it here.
I think it's called a,
so he's a thing.
He gets the guys trying to get a single,
so he's got his legs in between.
Um,
he's got Schultz leg in between his legs.
Schultes locks up,
double wrist lock and drops and rows and just destroys his arm.
Just destroys it.
It's really interesting.
[inaudible] I,
I saw Kimora on one is old black and white pre World War II.
Juno videos do the same exact take down with the gate.
Oh yeah.
He locked up the Camorra the same exact way and throw the guy you want me to say
that one more time?
I love watching that.
It's absolutely brutal,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
He was his qualify for that.
Yeah,
I believe so.
I'm pretty sure once I does this crank,
my shoulder's gone to the guy.
You could just see the guy that he just collapsed.
And I get how that's a very similar to when a Frank Mir Brookman the Toros arm.
Yes.
Yeah.
I remember that man.
That was like,
they want to tap and heads got his arm broken by Sakharova.
Yup.
Yeah.
Sakuraba is almost the same type of situation where it was a standing Kimora and
he was trying to throw him and I think Hanzo resisted by straighten the arm,
but it was enough torque that it,
uh,
it,
it popped.
I believe Hanzo had his back and just got a little relaxed because I think Kenzo
was winning the fight.
Henzel had soccer,
rob is back and you know,
soccer rob,
when he had his back,
that's when he would lock that up and he said,
uh,
Henzel talked about it recently.
So just really surprised at how strong Sakharova was.
Oh,
he's a strong little dude man.
Cause he had been rolling in are fighting rather with much larger guys.
Like he fought Conan and Sylvia and the first UFC when he fought in Japan and
was a 98 maybe.
And he was,
you know,
one 90 something and Conan is like two 50 and a,
he tapped him with an arm bar,
if you remember that.
And it was like one of the first times we ever saw a Brazilian jujitsu black
belt get tapped.
We were like,
whoa.
That was the introduction of the world to Sakharova.
Well,
you know,
it's funny when,
as a kid,
uh,
York barbell was like the Mecca for strange training in those days.
And Bob Hoffman,
the father of American weightlifting weight training.
He had the system called the heavy light system where you would use heavyweights
one during one session and then lighter weights the next.
But the letter wastes weren't that light.
They just felt bike.
Cause you had used heavyweights before and sometimes even in the same session,
you would hold a really heavyweight and then when you go to your normal weight,
it felt ridiculously light.
Hmm.
Right.
I used to do that in wrestling.
I called up my heavy light system and I would spar with all the heavyweights,
uh,
on our team,
all the big boys.
And then when I went with God in my own way,
they felt like toys.
Yeah.
Makes Sense.
The heavy light system,
and I,
I've,
I've talked to a lot of guys that had experience wrestling with big guys,
you know,
in Jujitsu and so forth.
It does truly make guys your own weight.
Feel like nothing you would,
I would imagine so.
But it's also like really bad on your joints.
You gotta be careful,
man.
You got to really,
really,
really be careful.
This.
That's a young man's technique.
It's,
I would not use the heavy light system myself,
man.
Have you ever seen that video of the really old judo master rolling with all of
the students?
It's a block and black and white,
but yeah,
it's amazing.
What was that guy's name,
Matt?
I don't remember Jamie's CV.
You could find it.
Old Judo master tools.
Young students.
I mean he was,
it was black and white.
He had that floating throw the,
what is it called?
The floating drop or value dropped throughout man.
He was just like tossing these guys.
Yeah.
And you could tell,
I mean,
this was not like some sort of a kung food demonstration.
I that was like real,
this is it.
Yeah.
This is the guy,
this old dude guys,
good jammies on the ball to me.
But for me,
I mean,
how old was he?
I believe he was in his sixties at the time.
Does it say it in the,
uh,
the description of a Jamie,
see what it says it in that?
No.
Well,
he's no spring chicken.
Yeah,
I believe he was in his sixties.
I mean,
he's got all his,
all gray hair,
but look how relaxed so relaxed,
so frail.
That wasn't judo.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
Look how he moves,
but look,
look how beautiful he say,
how he checks in with the hip and he's a little guy.
This guy's huge,
big difference in size.
Like maybe like 30 or 40% at least we look at that kind of go on with it.
He checks him with the hippie just as enough to have to get throng.
I mean,
it looks like they're dancing.
It's amazing.
It's a beautiful thing,
man.
Every time this guy tries to me,
they're all,
they're all wearing wipe out.
So that's was kind of cool.
Yeah,
right.
No,
there were no belts.
That was,
so that was even before there were belt.
Is that the case?
Look at that.
Boom.
It was like,
well,
during the 60s or whatever,
they started coming up with the whole belt system.
Really during the 60s it was really late.
It was late in the,
no,
Kybella.
Yeah.
So judo,
all he told me that,
and in Brazilian Jujitsu that there was one belt,
Eh,
when you became a,
after you've trained for five years,
you put on a blue belt and that signify to the senior student.
Really one belt.
But we one belt that's,
and then when the judo,
uh,
started with their belts that she was Jitsu also around the same time.
So when did the black belt get introduced?
And that was when the color belts were introduced.
I believe it was during the 60s.
I end up pre world war two.
There were no belts.
Look how beautiful,
effortless that throw us,
this gorgeous,
effortless,
this old frail guy,
just using perfect technique.
Just so much knowledge,
so much.
Now look at that.
Look how beautiful that is.
The guy tries to do to him when he did to him and this kid has going for it.
I mean,
he's shown respect,
but he's,
he's trying to throw the,
Oh man,
there's no doubt that he was.
Yeah,
he just knows what he's,
he's,
yeah,
he's not,
um,
he's not trying to bully him.
He's trying to use technique.
But it look at that.
Oh my goodness.
It's amazing.
I just love watching that.
I love,
love watching that.
And there's,
there's really a difference in this in comparison to striking arts because you
know,
if these guys were kickboxing after a few leg kicks,
well as long as you know how to do break falls,
you
can,
Oh God,
that's so beautiful.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
yeah,
there's no,
I mean,
I find that with the grappling arts you can pretty much keep going for much
older.
You certainly much older than sparring with striking.
But you know,
it's a a sounding,
but this book I'm reading about the history of Brazilian Jujitsu and uh,
they were talking about like the Japanese,
when they first came to America,
it was the first clash of cultures.
The judo man,
we're finding that they couldn't stand up to the American catches catch can
wrestlers.
The Americans were bigger,
stronger,
faster,
heavy.
They couldn't take them down with a lot of this throws,
a lot of the wrestlers won't wear the jackets.
That's where the guard really became developed,
really found that if they could pull them into the guard,
they can dispatch them with farmlogs triangles.
Sometimes he insisted that the wrestlers wear the jackets in these fights like,
uh,
like my Ada.
And then of course they could set the choke pretty easy on these guys.
Very fascinating book.
It's,
it's really fun.
I bought it off Amazon and have it on my kindle.
I'm halfway through it right now.
I'm just to the point now where my Ada starts teaching Carlos Gracie why?
But the history of the sport is absolutely fascinating.
That's incredible.
Have you been paying attention at all to Metamorris?
Oh yeah.
Well,
my son Zach,
that was a tough match for him.
He doesn't do no,
Gee,
that's not his game at all.
He's always only doing it.
Yeah.
And I said,
Holy Shit.
For your first professional blackbelt match,
Gary,
Tony,
could you expect like a hardware guy?
Yeah,
Gary Tournament's coming on this week.
I really,
I really questioned,
you know,
like,
wow,
that's,
he just said,
hey,
you know what?
I just wanted a challenge that's just really want to fight.
That was the top guy and Gary,
Tony,
anytime you talk about Nogi submission wrestling,
that names up there with the bass man,
did you see his match with Kroll?
Oh my God.
Amazing.
I don't even know how calm pulled that out man.
He's a man as you serious crime but yeah,
it's like so yeah,
so I'm metamorris had dean lister versus Josh Barnett.
Josh Barnett of course representing catch wrestling.
Josh Barnett even came out like an old catch wrestling bikini bode shorts,
the shoes,
the shoes and tapped dean lister with a headlock with that,
that judo headlock from from side control.
All you guys out there,
you blue belt and purple bots.
Don't forget to practice your headlock escape man.
Because you know,
and Jiu Jitsu training,
no one uses the head lockers.
It's usually pretty easy to escape from.
Also,
you give up your back kind of.
Exactly.
When you get out of a headlock you were in a pretty crappy position.
Right?
But if you don't practice it,
man,
you can see what happens.
I mean you get a high level athlete like Josh Barnett who is ridiculously strong
and he slaps it on you by surprise.
Even a professional like dean and I mean Dean probably knows a hundred escapes
from a headlock,
but man,
he had caught by surprise get locked up in that thing,
man.
You know,
that same position.
I was actually giving a seminar for the United States secret service.
I used to go down,
they were just a 90 minute drive from my gym,
Philadelphia.
And I uh,
I got to know some of these guys through Pavel and I used to go down and give a
self defense seminars as well as conditioning and Ken about seminars.
So one of the guys was an ex wrestler who got me in that position that Josh got
dean.
I made a big mistake,
man.
The guy says,
well how do you get out of this position?
You know?
And so I lay down and I'll leave them do it to me,
but the Saturday gun crank me with it and pop both of my ribs and I was crippled
for eight weeks.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was pretty jerk thing to do.
Of course,
you know,
he would typically a typical herky jerky type of wrestler.
I was one of those guys myself at one time,
but I just realized how dangerous that position is.
That's how Mark Coleman beat Dan Severen to when the first ever UFC heavyweight
title at same exact position.
And I'll tell you,
man,
it is a power move,
but man,
if a guy knows how to do it right,
it freezes your diaphragm.
It can dislocate your ribs,
it can even cause some spinal damage.
It's just horrible to be caught in it and you go into an immediate panic.
But uh,
yeah,
you can really get hurt with that.
Not just NEC,
but
ribs.
It's a power move,
but isn't a gating as well.
I mean,
there's a technique to it,
but as a technique to it and you certainly have to have some strength to pull it
off.
Yeah.
Well if you're wrestling anymore,
buddy,
you're on size or a little bit smaller.
And Josh,
his case,
he was bigger than dean.
Hell,
why not?
And that
not much bigger than Dean Dean's huge.
Yeah.
Dean's a pretty big boy.
He's really big now.
I mean,
he's a way thicker than when he was fighting at two oh five in the UFC.
I Dunno what he's walking around on,
but he looked to me to be like in the two forties or two thirties,
at the very least.
I went out it,
yeah,
he's very thick.
But Josh,
Josh got him in that position.
He couldn't escape,
which is amazing when you consider how much experience Dean has.
And uh,
I don't think he had been tapped in competition over decades.
A hard guy to chat,
man.
Oh so hard at the skill level,
his skillset.
But Hey,
both guys are fantastic.
And you know,
that's,
that's grappling,
right?
And any given day,
I love also the different approaches that Josh has a different approach and you
see that that different approach,
that cast wrestling approach can be just as effective if he gets you in one of
those positions.
You know,
it might be something you're not accustomed to,
so you haven't trained to get out of it.
I remember one of the first pro,
uh,
grappling matches.
It was in,
maybe you remember this,
it was like in one of the Carolinas,
North Carolina or South Carolina.
It was,
I think it was called the pro am or something.
There was a guy along goes this,
oh man,
back in the nineties maybe?
No,
it was real early,
like late nineties.
Was this the one where frank shamrock a wrestle Dan Henderson and they did like
a paper view thing and John Perretti was the,
it wasn't
a paper view,
but they were paying cash prizes to the guys.
It was like one of the early attempts to do submission wrestling as a pro sport.
Okay.
And uh,
I remember Salo was at the house,
he was training solid Humira,
so a bear.
And he was wrestling the supposedly like the number one catch wrestler.
He was living down in North Carolina somewhere.
And I had seen this guy in other tournaments and I warned him,
I said,
hey,
this guy will give up his back to go for that twisting tow haul.
You know,
like when you go,
they loop over the toe hold and kind of flip upside down and go for your foot.
And I said,
the guys good with it.
He's really good and wouldn't,
you know,
solid takes the back and the guy does it and pops his ankle.
But Sala won't tap.
He said he would have died before he tapped it as catch wrestler and then
because he didn't tap,
you know,
he,
he choked the guy over the face.
You know,
cause the guy was trying to hide the chin,
basically just put the guy out man,
and didn't mangle his ankle but mangled the angle.
So he won.
But Oh my God,
that thing turned his black is this microphone man.
It was like he was in such pain that surgery.
Now he did it and he's like,
man,
I'll tell,
I saw as another one of those guys that just like one of the toughest dudes I've
ever met,
him and his brother to Sean's here,
just like so tough.
But man,
he limped around and was hurt.
I don't know where the ankle was ever the same,
but that's one of those deals,
right,
with the catch wrestlers.
Gotta Watch those guys are tricky is o hell,
I see different things.
He's the feet man.
Yeah,
it's guys doing different things and getting really good at those things.
That's,
that's a big part of it.
It's like if a guy has a like a a foot lock or something like that,
he just has down,
he just knows how to do it and that becomes his thing.
I mean some guys just have certain positions that you're not really well versed
in and they go to it over and over and over again.
Like Eddie Bravo before he got famous for doing the twister.
One of the things I remember in John Jocks,
Eddie Bravo would do a told he was a toehold guy.
He and he would get told on guys all the time because a lot of people weren't
good at toeholds so he would dive on told he was always catching people
that don't know how the defend a man.
Yeah,
it's a smart move and sometimes moves.
They're so old,
they're new.
You know what I mean?
Like you'll see things go in trends and then people get good at stopping him and
they kind of go away.
And then some older move,
we'll come back and you see these waves.
It's a,
it's funny like I was sort of anti bear and Bolo and some of these [inaudible]
version techniques.
Maybe I'm just jealous cause I,
you know,
my spine a little bit too old and stiff to do it,
but the guys who look like they're having a good time when they do it,
but,
uh,
I,
I was talking to my son and he says,
well dad,
he says,
you can still got to learn that stuff.
He says,
even if you don't want to use it,
you got to learn it to say,
you know how to stop it.
He says,
because for sure if you don't know what you're going to get tapped,
you guys going to catch it.
Right.
So you got at least practice it a little bit to be familiar with it.
And that being said is in New York City and as a wrestling with Gianni Grippo
and,
uh,
Mr [inaudible],
the guys so much fun.
He's one of more Cielo,
a black belts.
This kid is so good with that and it was really fun playing with him with that
thing,
man,
he could just flip upside down and roll and invert and next thing you know the
little suckers on your bag is like,
how did he do that man?
Yeah.
It's really interesting when guys get super sharp at one particular technique
and if you're not aware of that particular technique,
it could become really dangerous.
You know?
Um,
Braulio a steamer is famous for having that very bizarre guard as well,
where he'll do those reverse triangles or inverted triangles and he gets himself
into a position where for to the outside observer it looks like,
wow,
this guy is on his neck here and it's weird position.
And then all of a sudden he's got a triangle on the guy and he's like,
what happened?
People just so good at that position.
He's good at all positions,
positions.
That one position he's been particularly successful at because it's such an
unusual thing to defend.
Very few people are that scary with it.
And it's like some people like criticize certain techniques,
they go,
ah,
you know,
I played around with that,
but that doesn't work well.
Okay,
really well.
What about like head kicks?
Did you play around with a headcase?
And he'd say they don't work because you know,
many times you have to drill a head kick to get it effective,
but then you get it up to like a point where like an Anthony Pettis has it or an
Anderson Silva has it and it becomes a real dangerous weapon in your arsenal.
Cro,
cop,
perfect example,
cro,
cop drilled that damn head kicked to the point where he could throw it out like
another guy could throw a straight punch.
It's a standard straight punch.
That's how good and fast his head kick was and still is.
And when you,
you discount a technique simply because you don't have the proficiency in it,
you could really,
really get caught because you,
you really can sort of define the world and an inaccurate light.
And then you see a guy like maybe this bear and Polo Guy or Eddie Bravo with his
twister,
or you know,
there's a million different techniques that you're,
you're starting to see emerge in MMA.
That guy's a discarded,
like the front kick to the face.
Nobody was worried about the front kick to the face,
nobody.
And then all of a sudden Anderson acts out Vituro like when you're like,
holy Jesus,
no one ever expected,
but say this is the thing.
I mean he can't learn everything for sure.
You know,
you got to have your certain arsenal,
but it certainly pays to be familiar with these positions and at least learn the
rudimentary basics so you understand it,
what it is,
you can recognize it because recognition is the first step to protect yourself
against this stuff.
So even if you never want to use it,
it,
it pays to at least learn it and be familiar with it and actually learn it
offensively.
There's a mistake that exact do,
especially wrestlers that are learning Jujitsu,
they decide water's going to learn defense.
I'm just going to learn Jujitsu defense.
You will never learn correct.
Jujitsu defense and less.
You learn Jujitsu offense.
If you don't know how to cinch up a choke.
If you don't know how to cinch up an arm bar,
you're never going to know exactly what you can get away with when you're
defending.
And once you,
once you get adapt at or offense,
then you'll truly understand defense cause you'll understand what would I would
be trying to do to me if I was in this position and how do I stop this guy from
doing that?
All those little details.
It's like so,
so important.
Well,
so that's one of the most beautiful things about Jujitsu is there's so many
techniques.
It's almost like,
you know,
you seem never ending.
Yeah.
And you see certain guys who have a very small wheelhouse of techniques if they
utilize,
especially like attacks like Marcella Garcia was of course one of the best of
all time.
But he has a very,
if you look at his,
if you took all of his Jujitsu matches that he's won and look at how he won
them,
it's a very small number of chokes that he's used.
I mean it's almost all,
I mean I think Ricoh Rodriguez,
I think he got in with a leg lock.
Um,
most guys,
he got Jake shields with a wrist lock I believe,
and one of those,
uh,
and I remember Rico Chaparral,
he had a professional Jujitsu tournament thing that he was doing in Los Angeles.
Shakuri competed against Randy coture and Marcello competed against Jake shields
and I believe he got Jake and Arice lock,
which is,
you know,
he's got some crafty shit in there.
It really crafty,
but most of it,
Dia Tienes,
north south choke,
rear naked choke.
It's almost all next,
almost at all attacking the next,
it's,
it's a,
Jujitsu is such a complex sport.
It,
I liken it to a,
like a,
I like him wrestling and being a former restaurant,
more like checkers and Jujitsu to chess,
but not just chest,
three dimensional chess.
It really is maybe submission.
Wrestling would be more like regular chest and then re Jujitsu with the gate
with all the different ways you can manipulate the cloth.
Almost like three dimensional chess.
It's just such a huge variety of,
of stuff.
Yeah.
The only problem I have with the ghee is a,
I think a lot of people get brainwashed into thinking that you need to learn to
g to be good at Jujitsu and MMA.
And Eddie Bravo in particular is very adamant that that is a ridiculous idea.
He's like,
that's like saying you have to be really good at racquetball to be good at
tennis.
Yeah.
It's two different sports all together was just so much to grip.
And you see so many guys that are world champions or the competed a very high
level with the g and then they fight an MMA and everyone's sweaty and they have
gloves on and they can't grab things and they,
they say specific man,
you have to develop the specific skills towards your fighting conditions.
But,
uh,
you know,
one of the most elegant definitions of Jujitsu I ever heard,
and it's,
it came from house and crazy.
It was at a seminar in Atlantic city.
This is like one of the early Gracie seminars.
And uh,
this is back
in the day when he never knew what kind of Wacko was going to walk in through
there.
Sometimes you'd even get people that one of the challenge in the seminars and
there was this guy that came in,
I swear to God with flowing robes,
like this kung fu guy with this big red sash.
And so w right in the middle of the seminar,
he interrupts,
well Mr Gracie,
sir,
could you,
could you give me the definition of your philosophy of Jujitsu?
And we're like,
oh boy.
Because you know Helson his English wasn't the most,
it was hard to understand sometimes,
you know,
plus he mixed it with the Hawaiian Slam,
but he says when the fight,
when I know I can win the fight,
I can pretty much,
you know,
be that nice guy and kind and loving and all that towards other people.
Cause you know,
I had that confidence with myself that I know I can,
I can protect myself,
I don't have to be insecure.
So the guy says,
well,
could you expound on that?
And of course first we have to explain what expound means,
all that.
And we're thinking,
man,
what's he going to say here?
And he says,
Jiu Jitsu,
if you do dis,
I do that and if you do that,
I do this forever.
And we said,
Whoa,
that is some deep shit.
It's getting a three by five cards.
And I actually had that in my school.
I actually wrote that and put it on the wall.
If you do this,
I do that.
And if you do that,
I do this for ever.
And it's like wow,
it does.
It goes into infinity man.
Especially when you're constantly moving one step ahead of the guy.
Like if you,
I liken it to having a conversation,
like if you have a conversation with someone who speaks very broken English,
you could really kind of talk circles around them.
You could just,
if you're an articulate person,
especially of course you can make them look really silly.
He'd be like,
what?
What are you trying to say?
You're trying to say nothing.
You don't even know how to talk my language stupid,
you know?
And you could just literally do just rattle on,
attack them.
I think they call it soft history.
Is Sophos a lawyer?
Well,
some guys,
you know,
be aggressive and rude about it,
but some guys can do that with Jujitsu where you kind of have to think yourself
through every step and you're not kind of aware.
I mean,
that's how I always feel when I would roll with guys who I got a really,
really high level and it's like I'm not prepared for all the steps that you
could take to counter my step.
You know,
I will do a move and you will do your mood,
but you also have all these you,
you were already anticipating to counter this.
I've got to do that.
So I'm going to stop this by putting my hand on your knee here and putting my
foot on your hip here and now you're going to have to try to get out of it.
But I'm not going to let you get out of it because I'm already anticipating that
as I'm already so far.
Yeah,
like Hixon Gracie,
he always used to say about guys,
he's not going to be able to keep up the rhythm,
not gonna be able to keep up the rhythm.
You know that like you're going to,
I do this and you do that.
I do this,
you do that.
I this.
How long can you keep that up?
How long your teeth that really,
how long?
Well it Helton another go into.
Yeah,
it was amazing because the guy was pretty profound and is a very simple way.
The way he had explained things,
it was
pretty amazing but simple.
Roddy was complainant.
How easily he was catching him and says,
look,
I know everything you know and everything else.
Cause like,
yeah,
absolutely.
He says maybe,
maybe if I got sick or injured and was in the hospital for like three years and
did train.
Maybe if I came back you might have a chance.
But it's true.
It's true.
I wouldn't it be true to me the guy's done it is what I mean.
Ronda Rousey born Warren under Matt.
Yeah.
Ron has been saying that about a female opponents.
He's like,
she was like,
listen,
what's going on now is I've been doing this my whole life and these girls are
just not going to catch up to me.
And that's what you're seeing.
When we saw that beautiful arm bar that just landed on Zingano,
I mean it's in Ghana.
What tax?
Unbelievable.
And it tries to throw a Rhonda addressed winds up on top,
recognizes the position where the arm is.
I mean I was talking to George Greer Gel and uh,
about it at the last UFC.
He's like,
that's when I bowed down to Rhonda and that's how he said it.
I mean George is a black belt as well and he's like,
you know,
I saw her arm bars.
I was like,
yeah she's got a good arm.
Bars was sometimes she does things that I don't agree with.
So it looked like maybe her knees are a little too wide apart even though she's
catching these girls.
Maybe she's catching these girls cause they're just not that technical.
He goes,
well when she hit that on barns in Ghana,
14 seconds and he's like,
look I got a bow down.
That's some high level,
high level,
high level technique man.
The ability to adjust and again that language that she has in her head,
she's so articulate with the language of submissions.
And in her case armbars you know,
just so good at arm bar.
What a talent,
Huh?
It looks like she has quite a buddy movie career as well.
She,
she's not a battle.
Some gals beautiful aside the swimsuit issue or whether the man,
she's good figure a pretty girl.
Toughest Shit.
So very funny.
Um,
interview where this guy was talking a little trash and she,
Judith,
she landed Ottoman Poker Hardwood for oh man,
did she,
she broke the guy's red.
She judo through him and launched herself on top off of him.
If I'm,
she knew exactly what she was to too,
by the way.
You all right.
Are you all right?
We got an it guy.
You don't trash talk to?
Uh,
you just don't trash by that man.
I think it was kind of like let it out in advance.
He think,
what did he think?
He's wanting to get attention to make a video.
You put on a gay and a and then you trash talk to the girl.
Like,
like you're not going to,
uh,
yeah.
Well,
people got upset when I said that.
I think she could beat a lot of men in her in that way.
I don't know why they would,
well cause they don't know.
I've never rolled with a girl who is really good.
I made like in a natural world,
right outline this can sometimes beat a male line if they're the same size.
Yeah.
I mean you never know.
And if she has cub,
she'll risk your life to,
and maybe he could beat her,
but her incentive
is way higher than his incentive.
So he figures it's not worth it.
Well technique is,
as we said before,
is paramount.
And her technique is so laser sharp.
If she got in there with a guy who doesn't have that good a technique,
just because he's a man,
the physical strength and the inherent,
the benefits of being a male,
whatever advantages that he may have aren't necessarily going to counter the
technique that she has when they're the same weight.
Now if you're dealing with a guy like you know she's,
she competes at one 35 okay.
If you deal with her versus a guy at one 70 like Johnny Hendricks,
like Jesus of course that's a Mitch match.
Johnny Hendricks is a powerful big strong man and he most likely would beat her
up.
But you're talking about a guy who's her weight and then even if he's physically
stronger,
maybe can hit harder.
But how much of a technical advantage does she have on the ground?
She can easily catch you in something in a scramble easily,
easily.
Well,
you know,
two,
three,
four steps ahead of you for,
for older guys like myself,
actually the women are some of your best bar partners,
like the more advanced women,
they're fun to train with because they're not going to try to muscle it.
They don't usually,
it's rare occasionally,
but usually women won't use power.
They do think differently than men.
They have a different logic and they surprise the heck out of you with some of
their attacks and the way they put their game together.
It's really fun.
And usually women are pretty flexible,
so their guards are a nightmare to get some of these girls with their daily
havens,
spider guards,
like wow.
Controlling those feet are,
is a nightmare.
Yeah.
And you think about someone's guard.
Someone's legs have to carry their body around,
you know,
say if they weigh 140 pounds like Rhonda or one 35 and you know you're carrying
135 pounds around.
All by the way,
she doesn't really weigh one 35 she was one 35 on weighing day.
And then I would imagine she rehydrates up to around one 50 close to it.
She does.
She's pretty,
she cares a lot of muscle in that frame.
It's just thick.
And she's not,
she's not a skinny girl by any stretch.
Yeah.
She's not week by any stretch of the imagination.
She's very strong.
And so you're dealing with someone who knows how to manipulate their body and
they have these legs that are carrying around all of this weight all day long.
Your legs are amazingly strong.
It's amazing endurance.
And when you factor that in,
if you've gotten like I remember doing drills with my friend Felicia,
Felicia.
Oh,
it's one of John Joc Machado's black belts.
Yeah,
I know Felicia from the old RKC Kettlebell.
Yeah.
She's a kettlebell wizard.
She loves that.
But I remember doing drills with her and you know armbar drills and she locks
and arm bar up on you man.
And you're dealing with legs.
Legs are strong man.
Even a small woman has very strong legs.
Well,
the difference between male and female legs is very small percentage.
You know in studies,
if they've done a upper body,
there is a significant
difference.
But where's the train woman?
She can close that gap and I'll tell ya for,
for you older guys listening out there,
you know,
you guys over 40 or if you're a guy that's been injured,
start seeking the girls out for sparring partners and you will have a wonderful
technical spar session.
You also look like a little bit of a creep.
Yeah,
alumnae heads up.
Just don't be afraid to tap.
Yeah,
that's a big one with guys tapping to girls.
Oh my God.
Some guys want to bleed from the eyes before though tapped her growing up every
time to a girl.
Oh hell yeah.
I haven't.
Ah,
AH,
well
I didn't say,
I didn't say what it,
what content
I would though.
I mean I'm sure Robert could probably,
if I,
if I get an a bad is I don't care who it is.
If it's,
if it's a child,
I'll tap if,
if,
if I'm now,
now I'm to the point where my days were fighting out of stuff.
If I'm,
if I,
if I make the mistake and I get into submission,
I have to assume that if it was a person of equal skill to myself,
um,
submitted,
he got me in this position.
Fighting out of it.
Is it really technique is much as just strength or whatever,
you know,
pain,
tolerance,
right.
I mean the technical escapes.
Sure.
But you know,
like you know what though?
The joint straight.
Right,
okay.
Especially when it's fully locked in Zach or focus,
he got me straight toward the chokes set.
It's just pain tolerance in or whatever.
It's also the,
the,
the price you pay just to keep your ego healthy.
Like physically.
I remember,
um,
my friend Brent got me in a Kimora and I didn't want to tap and I fought out of
it,
but I couldn't do chin ups for months.
I had hobos so jacked,
I couldn't do chin ups for the long.
And I just remember everyday I would be at the gym when I was lifting weights
going,
why the fuck didn't I just tap?
Because I would be fine right now.
Like either it was the same thing happened.
I've tapped to him before,
he's tapped me before,
but I just would not happen.
I'm like,
yeah,
you're just in that shrine center,
but you got to treat it like it's basketball.
Someone scores on you in basketball,
it's not the end of the world.
You've got the ball and you go right back in.
Or are you playing softball and you pop fly out in the outfield or you get
thrown out at third base.
So what,
okay.
You get another chance at bat.
But,
uh,
a lot of times like,
like you said,
even though you do fight out of it,
you are successful.
The injuries already occurred,
especially with the neck and you might not even feel it at the time,
but then it's like,
oh shit,
this really hurts man.
I didn't realize it was his damages.
There was maybe you're a little bit of adrenalized or,
that's why I love the,
uh,
the saying that the uh,
like Henna and here on you keep it playful.
Keep it.
Boy,
that's a great way.
It's a great philosophy and it's a great way to teach,
you know,
those guys have really done and the real boss Boston map,
I met those guys when they were just like little tiny boys.
They're so enthusiastic too.
It's very contagious.
Is they are,
they are very enthusiastic.
It does Gracie breakdowns that they do with a go over the techniques that guys
use and fights to win fights.
It's like,
it's very,
it's,
it really makes you want to train.
They're great.
They're great assets.
Do Jujitsu,
the great ambassadors.
I think so too.
I A,
I love that whole a straight fight.
Things that they do and they show like a,
the right things that people do are in the wrong things.
And then they get some pretty,
uh,
intense street fights on there sometimes.
So you're in town for how long and you're doing some seminars around here?
Uh,
I actually,
uh,
I came here it just to see you and then,
I'm going to be,
and
I don't know whether I should even mention in your show,
but a love line with that doctor Joe,
why shouldn't you mentioned it?
Oh Man.
You know,
it's kind of a,
isn't it like a competition podcast or something?
Oh,
no,
I don't think about it like that at all,
ever.
No,
no,
no.
A lot of friends doing that.
That's how old school radio mentality.
I never,
you know,
I support everything.
So,
yeah,
that,
that was a weird,
weird,
weird man.
I,
I just,
they just call it out of the blue.
Apparently the guys been following some of the anti aging stuff up,
doing the no touch or drew,
but the Mike,
yeah,
the comedian guy that's on there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's interesting.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah,
no,
I've never done anything like that before.
That's like,
Whoa,
that should be interesting.
Yeah,
it'll be fun.
Tell him I said Hi.
I had no idea.
You know,
like what to expect or tell them that you're getting into pot.
Yeah,
he's actually,
he's actually come around about pot human that Sanjay Gupta from CNN,
they're all coming around.
I came around,
you know,
it's like now that you're seeing it legalized,
but yeah,
I was,
I was a little concerned because like I wasn't sure what was it going to be like
a Howard stern thing where they tried to make it look like an idiot or no,
no,
I understand.
It's actually a pretty,
a pretty,
a pretty cool show.
So,
um,
I'll be doing that strength matters.
Summit in San Diego,
that's 20th through 22nd March San Diego.
I'm teaching a body weight workshop.
Where can people find all of this stuff?
Just on my website.
Maxwell S c.com,
ww dot.
Maxwell Sca for strength and conditioning.com and all of the upcoming things.
And then of course,
the El Salvador lifestyle,
uh,
Jujitsu training camp show you all the,
all my anti aging secrets.
Nice.
Hopefully,
you know,
mobility and conditioning and Jujitsu,
big emphasis on the self defense aspects of it,
but also we'll have some other young guys there,
uh,
for competition stuff.
And then,
uh,
I just came out with the five pillar workout system for kettle bells.
I have a mood,
like a movement based exercise.
I had a one with the body weight.
Now I came out with the Kettlebell five pillar movement system.
Just release that and I'm going to be making one with the barbell five pillar.
So Nice.
And here we go.
This is the uh,
the website here as well as c.com.
And uh,
you also custom tailor workouts for your clients through the Internet.
I do.
I discovered a long time ago,
about 15 years ago that uh,
a lot of people,
they don't need someone to hand hold them through workouts.
They had the incentive to train if they just didn't know what to do.
So I do die programs,
fat loss programs for people,
help them wade through all that huge information.
I've had my own personal diet wars with,
with myself and I pretty much figured out a way that you can keep lean year
round.
So I help people with diet fat loss and you know what to do.
There's so much bench,
uh,
information and misinformation.
W W how do you put all this together,
you know,
is difficult.
It's difficult to come up with a time to do all the research yourself and it's
all based in calls by the way.
There's so many different ways to crack the nut,
so many different systems and they all work more or less.
It just all depends on what it is that the guy wants.
So people really need a lot of help just sorting that stuff out.
So that's what I do.
And a extensive questionnaire,
uh,
I analyze a photograph for structure,
you know,
uh,
postural stuff and then,
you get a custom workout program and you send me training logs and I reviewed
them and sandy information back and do progressions with people and so forth.
Well,
I can't recommend you highly enough.
Thanks all the years that we've been friends,
I've just gained a tremendous amount of information from you and all the times
we worked out together and we're working out tomorrow too.
Damn Joe,
those guns are
very excited about that.
Um,
so anybody who interested in any sort of a strength and conditioning workout,
if you want to mix it up or we just want to just tap into the database of
knowledge,
that is Steve Maxwell,
Maxwell,
sc.com and all of these upcoming seminar dates all available there and you can
all check out,
uh,
on Twitter.
It's Maxwell sc on Twitter as well,
right?
Is Steve Maxwell sc on Twitter stream actually.
All right.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it man.
Always a good time to do this more often.
You're a traveling nomad though,
man.
You're all over the world.
Thanks.
We got him here for a little bit.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Take care.
Bye Bye.
Awesome Joe.
Thanks man.